ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is Dr.
Robin Carhart-Harris.
Dr. Carhart-Harris is a
distinguished professor
of neurology and psychiatry
at the University
of California, San Francisco.
He is one of the
leading researchers
in the field of psychedelics
and how they change
neural circuitry in the brain.
His laboratory is responsible
for understanding,
for instance, how
psilocybin, also sometimes
referred to as magic
mushrooms change
neural circuitry in the
brain, such that new ideas
and new forms of learning occur.
His laboratory is also
responsible for carrying out
various clinical
trials, some of which
have demonstrated that
appropriate dosages
of psilocybin can alleviate
major depression in more
than 67% of people
that take the drug.
Now, this is not to say
that everybody should take
psilocybin, and today's
discussion describes both
the clinical trials and why
treatments with psychedelics
in some cases work
and in some cases
do not work in order to
treat major depression.
As well as discussions around
psilocybin, lysogenic acid
diethylamide,
sometimes also referred
to as LSD, as well as DMT.
And how these change the brain,
and how those brain changes
can relate to changes
in mental health,
as it relates to depression and
other psychiatric challenges,
as well as how psychedelics
are being applied
in order to change neural
circuitry for sake of expanding
different aspects
of the human mind,
including creativity,
intelligence, and much more.
During today's discussion
Dr. Carhart-Harris
teaches us about the history of
the study of psychedelics, as
well as how the legislature,
that is the laws surrounding
psychedelics, are evolving
in the United States
and elsewhere for the
use of psychedelics
to treat psychiatric challenges.
By the end of
today's discussion,
you will have a
thorough understanding
of how psychedelics work.
Both in the short-term during
the actual journey or trip.
In fact, much of my discussion
today with Dr. Carhart-Harris
talks about the
different aspects
of the psychedelic
journey and how those
relate to therapeutic outcomes.
And, of course, by the
end of today's discussion,
you will also understand
the long-term effects
of psychedelics, that
is, how they can actually
rewire the brain.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor
is Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating,
and sleep tracking capacity.
I've talked many times
before on this podcast
about the fact that
sleep is the foundation
of mental health, physical
health, and performance.
One absolutely critical variable
to getting excellent sleep
is the temperature of
your sleeping environment.
That is, in order to fall and
stay deeply asleep at night,
your body temperature
needs to actually drop
by about 1 to 3 degrees.
And in order to wake
up in the morning
feeling refreshed and
alert, your body temperature
has to increase by
about 1 to 3 degrees.
There are a lot
of ways to control
the temperature of your
sleeping environment,
but one of the best
ways is to control
the temperature of
your actual mattress--
the surface that
you're sleeping on.
With Eight Sleep, you
can do this very easily.
There's a
simple-to-use app where
you can program in the
temperature of your mattress
across the night.
So you can make it slightly cool
at the beginning of the night,
getting cooler, putting you
into deep sleep, and then
rapid eye movement sleep.
And all of that, in terms
of its impact on your sleep,
can be tracked
within the same app.
I've been sleeping on
an Eight Sleep mattress
cover for more
than two years now,
and it has completely
transformed my sleep.
If you'd like to
try Eight Sleep,
you can go to
eightsleep.com/huberman
for their exclusive Memorial
Day savings now through June 5
2023.
Eight Sleep currently
ships in the USA,
Canada, United Kingdom,
select countries in the EU,
and Australia.
Again, that's
eightsleep.com/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is a program
that lets you
see how different foods affect
your health by giving you
real-time feedback on your
diet using a continuous glucose
monitor.
One of the most important
factors in terms of your energy
levels and your immediate
and long term health
are your blood glucose
or blood sugar levels,
as they're commonly called.
With Levels, you can assess how
different foods and activities
impact your blood
glucose levels.
When I did this, it
taught me several things.
First of all, it taught me
that certain foods really
spike my blood glucose levels.
And while spikes
in blood glucose
aren't always a bad thing,
I was able to assess
how certain foods were spiking
my blood glucose too much, such
that I would have post-eating
dips in energy levels.
And by removing those foods and
substituting in other foods,
it really evened out
my energy levels.
So if you're interested in
learning more about Levels
and trying a continuous
glucose monitor yourself,
go to levels.link/huberman.
Right now, Levels is offering
an additional two free months
of membership.
Again, that's
levels.link/huberman.
Today's episode is also brought
to us by HVMN Ketone-IQ.
Ketone-IQ is a ketone supplement
that increases blood ketones.
Now, most people have heard of
the so-called ketogenic diet.
But most people,
including myself,
are not on the ketogenic diet.
That is, I and most people eat
complex carbohydrates, fruits,
and things of that
sort in addition
to quality proteins, et cetera.
It turns out that even if you're
not following a ketogenic diet,
increasing your blood ketones
can still have benefits.
So for instance, I use
Ketone-IQ anytime I
want to do extended
bouts of focused work.
Preparing for podcast,
research, writing grants,
and if I ever want to exercise
but I don't have time to eat
or I don't want to have
my gut full of food.
Taking Ketone-IQ and thereby
increasing my blood ketones
allows me to do cognitive
work or physical workouts
without getting hungry and with
plenty of energy and cognitive
focus.
If you'd like to try Ketone-IQ,
you can go to hvmn.com/huberman
to save 20% off.
Again, that's hvmn.com/huberman.
I'm pleased to announce that I
will be hosting two live events
in September of 2023.
The first live event will
take place in Toronto
on September 12.
The second live event
will take place in Chicago
on September 28.
Both live events will include
a lecture and a question
and answer period
and are entitled,
The Brain-Body Contract, during
which I will discuss tools
and science related to mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And I should mention that
a lot of that content
will have absolutely no overlap
with content covered previously
on the Huberman Lab
podcast or elsewhere.
If you're interested in
attending either or both
of these events, please go
to hubermanlab.com/tour,
and enter the code "Huberman"
to get early access to tickets.
Once again, that's
hubermanlab.com/tour and use
the code "Huberman"
to access tickets.
I hope to see you there.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. Robin Carhart-Harris.
Dr. Carhart-Harris, welcome.
I've been wanting to talk
to you for a long time.
I certainly have known who
you are for quite a while,
because I place you in
this very small but very
special and important
category of researchers
who has been pioneering
the use of psychedelics
for the treatment of
specific clinical conditions,
and really carrying the
torch for, essentially,
the entire field.
So I want to start with
a voice of gratitude
and say thank you for doing
this incredibly important work.
Could you tell us a little bit
about what psychedelics are?
In fact, I'm curious as to
how the name psychedelic ever
came to be.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And what
you think they potentially
reveal about the
workings of the brain.
And then we'll talk about
the clinical applications.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Sure.
Well, even that one
is kind of hot one,
because opinions differ on
how to define psychedelic.
But perhaps, a
good starting place
is to start with the etymology,
where did the word come from?
And it was a Brit
excommunicated living
in Canada Humphry Osmond
who was due to present
a paper at a National
Academy of Sciences meeting
on psychotomimetics--
drugs that mimic aspects of
psychosis in their action.
And certain drugs
like mescaline--
let's see, 1956-- and
LSD were on the bill.
And he felt
dissatisfied with them
being under this category
of psychotomimetics,
and felt that the signature
psychological effects
of these compounds
went beyond just
mimicking psychotic symptoms.
And so he wanted to
find a more apt term
to speak to, in a sense,
the principal component
of their action.
And he jotted down a few
different possibilities
about a dozen or so, I think.
And one of them was
psychodelic, actually
it started as and ended
up being psychedelic.
And he had a correspondence
going on with another Brit
also living in the US,
Aldous Huxley, where
they were playing
with some terms
to refer to these compounds.
And in the end, Osmond
won with psychedelic,
and he had this little ditty of,
to fathom hell or soar angelic,
just take a pinch
of psychedelic.
That's where you put
the disclaimer in.
And so what does that mean?
It's two ancient Greek words
psyche, means the human mind
or if we're being actually
true to the ancient Greek it
means soul.
And then the other component
means to make clear
or to make visible or to
make manifest or to reveal.
So all of those work.
And it's a neologism.
It's a made up word.
But it does have that
ancient Greek origin.
And it's speaking
to this principle
that these compounds reveal
aspects of the psyche,
of the human mind, the soul
that are ordinarily not
entirely visible.
And so that's the etymology,
and it's wonderfully poetic.
But I happen to think
it's also very accurate.
It's a useful term,
because it's sort of,
you might say
valence nonspecific.
It doesn't say, you're
going to have a great time
or that you're going to go mad.
It's more that-- it reveals a
psyche, and it could be hellish
but it could be heavenly.
So that's the etymology and
also a bit of the psychology.
And sort of pointing
to the phenomenology,
the subjective experience.
But there's also a
pharmacology here.
And quite recently, there was
put out a consensus statement
about psychedelics
that's really referring
to what we call the classic
psychedelics to say that these
are all compounds that work
on a particular receptor
in the brain, the
serotonin 2A receptor.
And that's another way that we
could define these compounds.
I said this one's a little
hot, because I'm of the view
that while the pharmacology
is really useful, how
the drugs work chemically, you
can't avoid the phenomenology.
And if we're true
to the etymology,
where the term came from,
then we must recognize,
and we cannot neglect the
subjective experience.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Thank you
for that beautiful description
of what brought us
to today in terms
of using the word psychedelics.
And now, it's thrown
around all the time.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Too much.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
And I'm guessing--
well, not guessing.
I'm certain that it's also used
to describe many compounds that
don't touch the 5-HT2A,
the serotonin 2A receptor.
So there is a broader
categorization by most people.
And it'll be interesting to
see where all the nomenclature
and naming goes.
For the time being, I'd
love for you to tell us
a bit more about this idea
that psychedelics, however
one defines them, can reveal
something about the mind that
can't be revealed otherwise.
Are you talking about
the subconscious?
I mean, psychologists and most
famously, Freud but also Jung
and also neuroscientists, I
think, think about subconscious
processing.
I think, perhaps, the
most salient example
for me that's outside the
realm of anything psychedelic
would be blindsight.
This phenomenon that you take
people that are blind but still
have some connectivity
in their brain
and you present
them a board with--
or a computer screen with
different number of dots
on each side and you
say how many dots
are on each side of the screen,
and they say, what do you mean?
I can't see the screen.
I'm blind.
And you say, well, just guess.
And their guess rate
is accurate far more
than chance would predict.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So they
have so-called blindsight,
and people have said, well,
this is the subconscious
revealing itself.
There's no psychedelic
drug involved.
But what you're describing is
a pharmacologic-induced state
that reveals something that
normally should we assume is
masked or that we
are oblivious to--
even though it's
expressing itself.
What does it mean
for these drugs
to be revealing something about
the workings of the mind that
would not be obvious
to us, otherwise.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
So the example of blindsight is
interesting but it's different.
Blindsight would be referring to
non-conscious processing, maybe
implicit processing.
So stuff going on in
the mind in perception
in a sense that is
below the threshold
of conscious awareness.
But yet is influencing you.
So it's sort-- it's kind of
related, but it's different.
So in depth, psychology,
psychoanalysis, psychodynamic,
psychology, Sigmund Freud,
Carl Jung, and so on.
We talk about the unconscious.
And there, it's more
about the kind of blood
and guts of the human
condition, the human nature--
both the personal unconscious.
So things that
you might not want
to necessarily be conscious
of, because it's painful.
So that's the repression
aspect pushing it out
of conscious awareness.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Repressed
memories in particular?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Like traumatic memories,
difficult relationships.
It could be complex
trauma, not necessarily
just a specific index trauma,
but a series of trauma.
And then you have the
collective unconscious,
which was really Carl
Jung's contribution
to say that there's a
transpersonal quality
to the unconscious.
There's aspects about humans,
not just this individual human.
There's aspects to our
minds, our psyches that
are not fully available
to conscious awareness,
but can come up
in certain states.
Psychoanalysis went crazy for
dreaming as their royal road
to a knowledge of
the unconscious.
That was Freud.
But we now with
psychedelics, and this
was what drew me into the area.
Was discovering
literature that was
speaking to this particular
action, the psychedelic action.
And was saying that
when these drugs--
like LSD, psilocybin
found in magic mushrooms,
when they're used
in psychotherapy,
material comes up that may be
may have been repressed that
is of therapeutic value
and awareness and insight
of this material
seems to catalyze
the therapeutic process with
strong emotional release.
These cathartic
experiences and insights.
Whether they're insights
that are personal
or whether they're
transpersonal.
But for me, this is really
where the meat of it
is with psychedelics and classic
psychedelics, in particular.
The likes of compounds
like LSD and psilocybin.
I would say that if it
wasn't for this action
by classic psychedelics,
we wouldn't be
so interested in psychedelics.
I think, if we only had
compounds like ketamine, MDMA
cannabis, that could be
said, broadly speaking,
to be psychedelic-like.
I don't think it
necessarily would
have captured the world's
attention as psychedelics
are right now.
I actually think it's
a major gap to fill.
Is this principal action of
the classic psychedelics.
What does this mean
that I'm referring to?
Psyche-revealing.
What is that?
And I suppose where
I'm going with this
is, what is that in terms
of the biology as well?
What's going on in
the brain and the body
when people become
aware of things
that previously they
weren't fully aware of.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd
like to talk about some
of the clinical trials that
you've been involved with.
In particular,
looking at psilocybin.
As you mentioned, the principal
hallucinatory psychedelic agent
in magic mushrooms.
I'd like to start with a kind
of nuts and bolts question
just so that everyone's
on the same page.
I've read the papers
that you've published
and that others have
published in this area.
And typically, the dosages
used in these trials
are 25 milligrams of psilocybin.
And we talk about
one recent trial,
in particular, that
compared 25 to 10 milligrams
to more frequent use
of very small amounts.
1 milligram over 3
weeks, for instance.
However, when people talk
about magic mushrooms,
they often talk about gram
doses of the mushroom,
because I'm assuming that
they contain milligram
dosages of psilocybin.
Here, we're not encouraging
use of any kind.
These are clinical trials.
But for clarity of
understanding, what
is the conversion, typically?
Like 1 gram of
magic mushrooms will
contain how many milligrams
of psilocybin on average.
Because what I'm
trying to do here
is calibrate people to
this idea of microdosing
versus macrodosing.
And that's fairly
straightforward
to do with respect to
the clinical trials.
But then in a lot of the
lay discussion around this,
you hear about heroic
doses versus microdoses.
And so I think there's
a lot of confusion.
So if you would,
educate us on this idea
of what's a microdose.
And perhaps, also how many
milligrams of psilocybin
are contained in a gram of quote
unquote, "magic mushrooms?"
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Sure.
Well, a microdose is
neither of these are that.
Simple.
But they're fun.
It's a fun challenge.
But microdose, one
definition is that it's
a dose of typically a
classic psychedelic like LSD
or psilocybin that has some
perceptible psychedelic
effects.
It doesn't put you into a
noticeable altered state
of consciousness that
feels like you're tripping.
And if that was LSD, it
looks as though the threshold
is around about, let's
see, 10, 11, 12 micrograms.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Micrograms.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Micrograms.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Want
to be very clear here.
Micrograms.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
10 micrograms of LSD,
are you saying will not induce
visual hallucinations in most
people?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: So
that's threshold level.
That's about the level that
some people who are sensitive
could feel it.
But if you were to talk
to the microdosing gurus,
they might say that that's
the ballpark for an LSD dose
that you would
consider a micro dose,
and then you would
take semi-regularly.
It's typically
something like one day
on, one day off or one
day on, two days off.
This kind of thing.
There's different protocols.
And yeah.
So some like Jim Fadiman--
one of the popularizers
of microdosing, I think
would say that a true microdose
should be sub-perceptible.
You shouldn't feel
it, yet the assumption
is it's going to change you
in some way on a kind of trait
level more than a state
level, and maybe behaviorally.
And the typical story goes,
it will improve well-being.
And maybe, maybe,
it could improve
certain aspects
of cognition, say,
related to creative thinking.
I emphasize the maybe
there because that's
another angle with microdosing.
We're waiting for some
compelling evidence.
As things stand
right now, I'd say,
we lack that
compelling evidence.
There's some suggestive stuff,
but often the study designs
aren't that strong.
It's really hard to do a
study with microdosing,
because you need to have
permission to give people
a microdose that for
practical reasons,
they would go home with,
otherwise, you're requiring
them to be in the lab, say
three times a week for x number
of weeks to meet the criteria
of a course of microdosing,
which might be two or three
times a week for say, a month.
And that's a hard thing
to do in a lab study.
It's expensive.
You'd need to do that
against a suitable control,
so a placebo control.
And there is a study
that's been done
in New Zealand that has some
interesting preliminary data
that did--
I think did the design right.
But it hasn't been
published yet.
I've seen some positive
findings presented
around improvements in mood.
But it's a bit early to
get too excited about that.
It needs to go through
peer review and all that.
But as things stand, the
evidence is pretty thin.
And we have to be
honest about that.
We did quite a creative study
with my colleagues at Imperial.
The guy leading that, Balazs
Szigeti, a Hungarian chap,
did a really creative design.
Very much his brainchild.
He instructed people to
do their own blinding,
their own
placebo-controlled blinding
of their own microdosing.
So this was a classic
citizen science study
like do it yourself science
where they would get their LSD
tabs and chop them up, put
them into gel capsules,
opaque, and have other capsules
that are the placebos that they
just close empty capsule.
And then there was a whole
barcode scan technique
so that you kind
of shuffle them up.
But they've got the
barcode in, the QR code.
So you can break
the code later on,
but once you've
shuffled them up,
you no longer know which
ones had the microdosing
and which ones are empty.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Was this LSD?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
This was LSD.
Also tried it with
mushrooms, but the issues
with the mushrooms was
people would burp sometimes.
They'd belch.
And then they'd have
this mushroom taste.
So then he instructed
people to get
some non-psychoactive
mushroom material to put in.
So it's really--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Not an easy study.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
--not an easy study.
And it was-- I love
that kind of science.
Real creative first
mover kind of science.
And the results
were fascinating,
because the short story is
that the microdosing didn't
compellingly beat the placebo.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It did not.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It didn't.
And he controlled,
because he asked.
He controlled for expectancy.
So people's positive expectancy,
which is, in a sense,
the vehicle that carries
the placebo response.
It's why you have a placebo.
Is that positive expectancy
can drive a therapeutic effect
to a large extent.
So you measured that
pre-trial and then used
it to correct for the response.
And how did it work?
Those who got a
placebo but thought
they got a microdose
did as well as those
who thought they got a microdose
and did get a microdose.
So it was the bigger effect--
the majority of the
effect was in thinking
that you got a microdose.
So in a sense, it was a victory
for the power of the placebo
response.
And it's created all
sorts of controversy.
People don't want to believe
it, that kind of thing.
But that's the beauty
of science, isn't it?
That science is not about
what you want to believe.
That right there is
the beauty of science.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
love that experiment.
Kudos to them.
I'm not going to attempt to
say his last name correctly.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: I tried.
Yeah.
Probably you made a mess of it--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: No.
No.
I think you got it.
You were involved in
a clinical trial that
was published last
year comparing
25 milligrams of psilocybin
to 10 milligrams of psilocybin
to a drug called escitalopram.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Lexapro.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Lexapro?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And this 1
milligram over a 3-week dosage.
I'm wanting to discuss the
results of that study a bit
and some of the other
trials that you've
done involving psilocybin
for depression,
the treatment of depression.
Could we calibrate ourselves?
25 milligrams of
psilocybin, is that what--
it's going to be a
perceptible dose presumably.
Hallucinations and all that.
And is that what
one would find in--
I'm guessing here,
if I'm accurate,
this does not mean that
I have experience here.
But 2 grams of mushrooms?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It's
more than that we think.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I missed that--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: No, no.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
I missed that one.
Went off on a tangent.
But yeah.
25 milligrams of
psilocybin would be--
we don't know,
and it's important
that I say that because
I wouldn't want people
to hear my answer
here, and then use
it to calibrate their
own dosing of mushrooms
and get it way off.
So it's guesswork.
And I would love to see someone
do a proper study on it.
And look at the
psilocybin content
in a given mass of psilocybin
mushrooms, magic mushrooms.
But to my knowledge, that
hasn't really been done.
Someone like Paul Stamets would
give a better answer here.
But I think the percentage
within the mushroom mass is--
of psilocybin in the
mushroom mass and psilocin
which is the metabolite
of psilocybin
is something in the 1%, a
little bit higher, maybe, range.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: OK.
So 1 gram, 1000 milligrams
of magic mushroom
would contain about 10
milligrams of psilocybin.
Is that right?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Broadly speaking, yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: OK.
Great.
That helps calibrate.
And I think, again, just
allows the layperson
to understand a
bit more of where
we're headed with
these psilocybin
trials and the results.
So we don't have to
restrict our discussion
to just that I clinical trial.
But if we include that
one and compare it
to some of the other
trials that you've done,
I mean, your laboratory
is seeing phenomenal--
in my opinion,
phenomenal results
in the treatment of, otherwise,
intractable depression,
major depression, which so
many people suffer from.
From two-- I suppose
there two sessions
of using psilocybin in these
ranges of 10 to 25 milligrams.
Do I have that correct?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: OK.
Could we talk a little bit
about what people typically
experience during
those sessions that
allows this phenomenal
transformation of mood
and state and trait as well?
And I'm especially
interested in whether or not
it is the experience
during those sessions that
is the trigger that's necessary
for the transformation
from a depressed to a
non-depressed state.
Because the impulse
is to think it is.
That what one thinks and
sees and hallucinates is--
and hears is so vital.
But of course, these drugs can
create neuroplasticity changes
in our neural wiring, presumably
for long periods of time.
So what are your thoughts
on the experience itself?
And maybe for those who have
not done these compounds before,
you could explain a
little bit about what's
typical for people,
and what you think
is leading to that incredible
positive and pervasive change
in mood, state, and trait.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: I would
say that it's more than impulse
that is leading us to think that
the experience is important.
It's really data and
converging evidence now.
So independent teams,
independent studies
are converging on the magnitude
of certain kinds of experience
rated, yes, with
subjective rating scales
is predicting
therapeutic outcomes.
Pretty strongly
and very reliably.
And so that's guiding us.
Now, could you say, well,
maybe those experiences
are some kind of epiphenomenon
of say, a central brain action?
Well, absolutely.
But then all experience
are epiphenomenon
by that principle.
And yet we care
about it, you know?
And it matters to us and
in our human relations
with each other.
So I think it does
matter to a human being
when they're in say, a
psilocybin therapy session,
and as the drug effects
begin to come on
and the body starts to feel
a little strange and tingly
and there's some
initial anxiety.
And then in their
mind's eye, they
start to notice patterns
and maybe colors
and then, maybe, those patterns
deepen and they're dynamic
and they have this
fascinating organic quality.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Are they--
patients in your studies
typically using an eye mask?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
they're in the eye mask?
So eyes closed?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's why
you said mind's eye as opposed
to looking out into
the clinical setting.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
And that's one of
the major differences
to psychedelic therapy
versus taking a psychedelic.
Is you shut your eyes.
And it's a world away
from taking a psychedelic.
Yeah.
A rave or something.
In a sense, good luck with that.
But in psychedelic
therapy, yeah.
It's settled conditions.
There's music playing.
And what I'm describing here
is very much the default.
There's actually very
little variability
between the different
sites that have done
this work on these conditions.
Typically, it's two people.
Ideally, mental health
professionals, at least one
who's a psychiatrist or
a clinical psychologist
or some other kind of
psychotherapist or psychiatric
nurse.
But ideally, two who
meet those criteria
with a individual who's ingested
the drug and music playing
throughout.
A kind of runway into taking
the drug and then throughout,
so there's continuity.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: They're music
with lyrics or without lyrics?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Without
lyrics, to begin with,
and the music typically
is spacious to begin with.
And then builds and
becomes atmospheric.
There might be, I don't
know, some tribal drums
in the distance or
something as it develops
or like the sound of a
bird in the distance.
A call.
And then as it gets into
more stronger drug effects,
the music starts
to coax emotion,
and very intentionally, strings,
for example, would come in
and it would be an
interesting experiment and one
that we'd love to do actually
to see whether if you were
to pull that out, whether the
psychedelic experience would
be as emotionally intense as
it is in psychedelic therapy
when you have music
there as a default.
And across the board, people
should find this remarkable,
because it kind of is.
All of the published
studies that
are now having such an impact
on psychiatry and beyond
have music there as
a staple component.
And we just take it as
assumption that it needs to be.
I tend to share that assumption.
But it's remarkable that it
hasn't been tested properly.
But it's there.
And if you were
to run with that,
and if you had a critical
agenda, you would say,
well, this is music therapy.
Why are you making all this
fuss about psychedelics
when it's music that's there
in all of these trials with all
these fantastic findings.
So there is something to that.
And this will tee me
up probably to talk
about psychedelic-therapy
being a combination treatment.
We have a hyphen
between the two,
because I share the hypothesis.
The assumption that
should be tested better.
There is a positive
interaction between the two.
That there's a synergy
between the two.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's why
it's psychedelic-therapy
with a hyphen, just
like Carhart-Harris.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: OK.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd like
to take a quick break,
and acknowledge one of our
sponsors, Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens, now called AG1,
is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Greens since 2012.
So I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic Greens
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets
me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics
in Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiotic health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains a number
of adaptogens,
vitamins, and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met.
And it tastes great.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and they'll give you five
free travel packs that make it
really easy to mix up
Athletic Greens while
you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year's
supply of vitamin D3 K2.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year supply
of vitamin D3 K2.
This is extremely
useful to hear because I
think most people think, OK.
Psychedelic.
Whether or not they
have experience
with psychedelics or not, get
some visual hallucinations,
some auditory hallucinations,
some synesthesia,
some visual auditory blending,
somatosensation, you know?
Rubbing a surface and
being able to elicit
the sounds in one's mind.
Of course, et cetera.
But so seldom do
we actually hear
about the specifics of these
clinical trials in a way that,
for instance, points to
music as one of the, perhaps,
key variables.
Now, you mentioned
that as people
enter these psychedelic states,
that there's a little bit
of initial anxiety.
About a year and a half
ago, I had a discussion
with Dr. Matthew Johnson who's
running some psilocybin trials
at Johns Hopkins, as you know.
And he mentioned the
critical importance,
at least in his
mind, to this idea
of the patient, quote
unquote, "letting
go" or allowing the experience
to take them someplace mentally
as opposed to
trying to constrain
their sensory and
cognitive experience.
I'm curious what your
reflections are on that idea.
And why it might be so
valuable clinically.
And this ties back to
this earlier discussion
we were having about
the unconscious
or about psychedelics
revealing something that's
there all the time but that
we don't have access to.
And again, I'm struggling
to find the right language
for this, because
we don't really
have a neural mechanism
like top-down inhibition
or something like
that to explain how
this unconscious
might be uncorked
in the psychedelic experience.
But to make it quite simple and
direct, how important do you
think it really
is for the patient
to feel like they are,
quote unquote, "letting go"
and what in the
world is "letting go"
in biological terms?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I think we'll
get there in terms
of having the neural
correlates of the mind
revealing itself to itself.
The emergence of the
unconscious into consciousness
or unconscious material
into conscious awareness.
It's a wonderful challenge.
It's a huge challenge, but
it's a challenge to embrace.
And letting go very
much is, again,
a staple component of
how the different teams
do this work in terms of
encouraging a willingness
to let go.
And when we started out
doing our depression work
and did that first trial,
it was the first trial
of psychedelic in a formally
diagnosed depression, you know?
Where that was the
target population.
A depressed population.
It was the first modern
study to do that.
And we visited
Hopkins, friends there
and were mentored on how to do
the guiding Bill Richards, Mary
Cusumano.
They were just so brilliant and
wise in their guidance to us
as how to do the
guiding in our trial.
And so this phrase of trust, let
go, be open, you'll hear a lot.
I don't know who fairly it
should be attributed to,
but I would attribute
it to Bill Richards.
Yeah.
Everything's borrowed.
You probably got it
from someone else.
But it's such a key principle.
And it's almost like
a mantra that you're
trying to instill in people.
Trust, let go, be open.
And those different
components where the trust
is about the therapeutic
rapport that, again, this
goes beyond just intuition now.
We formerly measured
therapeutic rapport.
We do it even with just a single
item, a visual analog scale
item, a subjective rating scale
item on the morning of dosing,
and we find that it's
a significant predictor
of the quality of the
experience that you
have under the drug in
the psychedelic therapy,
and then the therapeutic
outcomes x weeks or months
later.
So very powerful chain
of predictive components
there, but trust,
essentially, important.
And again, not just to intuition
but the data pointing to that.
Let go, there's a readiness
to surrender, to let go,
to not resist.
And we do measure that
too and see that it's
predictive of response.
And then the being open is
about a willingness to go there,
to confront, to be inquisitive.
Something that's
easier said than done.
Can be terrifying.
When you're dealing with a
very vulnerable population,
it's probably more--
the rule then, the
exception that they're
carrying some significant
adversity, life adversity
or frank trauma that
they've suffered.
And so that message of be
open, be willing to confront
and to go there is
really powerful.
And that's how it plays out.
And often, there is struggle.
There's something
going on that is I
don't want to be feeling this.
Make it stop.
That can be
nightmarish at times,
but it's very, very strong.
And with these big doses that
we give, it's very strong.
And actually, a
student that I've
worked with, I think now
doing a PhD, at Harry Brouwer
is working on a fantastic
project characterizing
the different phases of
the psychedelic experience
where the early
phase is dominated
by negative emotions and
negatively-valenced feelings
of anxiety and struggle.
And then it's a different
story in the latter half.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Could
I ask about that?
First of all, I think that's
fascinating and important
to analyze the different phases
and, again, I'm delighted
here because people
typically hear
about a psychedelic
journey but we never
really hear about the
stereotypic components
of the beginning, middle,
and end of that journey.
We know that there's a peak
and that there's a parachuting
down and et cetera.
But when you say that typically
there's an anxiety, maybe
some negative valence
in the early stage,
do you mean about the sensations
people are experiencing
or about some prior event
that's being called to mind
that they're remembering?
Likewise, for the positive
phase of the psychedelic
journey or trip are people--
do they still call it a trip?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: All right.
For the-- I guess,
we'll use trip.
For the psychedelic trip.
Are people feeling positive
about the experience like, uh.
Like there's been some
sort of breakthrough
or they're in a
calmer state, or is it
that they tend to be
focusing on prior events
that were positive.
So in other words,
is there a threading
through of some concept that
comes to mind for people?
Maybe about an earlier trauma
or maybe about a sense of self
or a sense of other forgiveness.
It could be any of these things.
But what do we know about the
finer details of all that?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
I would say, the
initial struggle
is more against the
general drug effects
than pinning it on
something specific.
It's more that normal
waking consciousness.
We have a sense,
generally speaking,
if we're well or well enough, a
sense of assuredness about what
is a table here and so on.
And we have that assuredness
to an extent about ourselves
as well.
It might be illusory,
but we have it.
And what the drug's doing is
it's breaking down all of that.
And it's scary as hell.
And if it's a big dose,
it's just like human nature
to rage against that a
bit and a bit like dying.
I don't want this.
It feels like I could be dying.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
might lose my mind.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
That too.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I'd never come back.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Those two are the classics.
Is oh, but I might know that
I've taken a psychedelic
and I might even know a
bit about psychedelics,
but I still fear that
I'm going to go mad
or I know that
generally speaking,
these drugs don't have
a high fertility risk.
I still think I'm going to die.
And it's very palpable
and that comes up.
So yeah.
I mean, those are
the core fears.
That those two and very
reliably, that comes up.
And it's really like
a basic drug action.
It's dose-dependent but
it's a basic drug action
that is forcing something
about the nature
of the mind and the
way it's made up
that makes it feel that way,
but it feels like I'm losing
my mind or it feels like
I could lose my mind
or that I could go insane
or that maybe I'm dying here
and this is bad.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You've
talked many times before
and have done really
wonderful work looking
at the changes in communication
between different brain areas
while people are under the
influence of psychedelics.
And I think the gestalt of those
data, correct me if I'm wrong,
is that compared to the
non-psychedelic state, that
under psychedelic influence.
There is far more--
let's just call it
interconnectivity
or communication between brain
areas that typically aren't
communicating, which
probably is not
surprising to people given
the subjective effects
of these drugs.
What is the evidence that
after the psychedelic journey
is over, that some
or perhaps all
of that enhanced communication
across brain areas
is maintained?
And if so, what role
do you feel that could
play in these incredible
positive therapeutic outcomes?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
So we've had some recent
findings in that direction
where, yes, it's true.
And picture says
a thousand words
that some people might be
familiar with are these two
circles project that
we did in collaboration
with some researchers where
ordinarily, the communication
is going on within
systems like other regions
of the visual system
will be speaking mostly
within the visual system.
There'll be a kind of
cliquishness or a modularity
to the quality of the
communication in the brain.
And then the cool finding with
psilocybin was the first paper,
is that the communication, yes.
It transcends these modules and
becomes much more inter-modular
crossing different modalities
and that effect correlated
with the magnitude of
the subjective effects
and then we replicated it with
LSD using different methods.
And a new paper
will come out soon
with DMT showing
a similar effect.
It's a bit of a debate
about what regions are most
implicated.
But the general effect of an
increase in global functional
connectivity is what we call
it or global communication
in the brain.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And this
is while under the influence
of these drugs.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
This is under the--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So putting
people into a brain scanner
while they are under the
influence of the drug.
Is that right?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That itself
must be quite an experience,
given that these
scanners are small tubes.
You're in a bite bar, you've
got a bite bar in your mouth.
That's quite a study.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
You don't always
have a bite bar, at least
with the psychedelics.
But yeah.
You've got to keep
your head still.
And you have the loud
MR scanner noise going.
But because it's regular, there
aren't too many surprises.
So it's actually
surprisingly tolerable.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You're
in a hospital setting.
So you're not worried about
what would happen if you had
a cardiac event or something.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
You got professionals around,
and most people generally
tolerate that setting quite
well, surprisingly well.
But yeah.
We do all that.
And yes, we do
see the opening up
of the communication across
systems in the brain.
And it does speak
to intuition about
the subjective experience.
The different modalities might
be blending with each other.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Sorry
for interrupting,
but I have to ask, is it
thought that the activation
of the serotonin
2A receptors what's
responsible for the increased
communication between brain
areas that under
normal circumstances
would not be communicated?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
So there's a few reasons why
some modeling work that--
computational modeling work that
first identifies where the 2A
receptor is and then looks at--
models its basic effect
on neural activity.
Will recapitulate the--
or recreate the effect
that we see actually in
the data with the scanning.
So doing the
computational modeling.
You can see the same effect by
knowing where the key receptors
are and then making them
do a certain thing that we
know psychedelics do.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I can
imagine two possibilities.
And I think it's important to
distinguish between these two.
One possibility is that the
activation of this serotonin 2A
receptor leads to
increased connectivity
and thereby auditory and
visual hallucinations emerge,
changed patterns of
thinking emerge, et cetera.
That's the obvious
interpretation.
But the scientist
in me has to ask,
is it possible that all of
that increased connectivity
is occurring, and yet that is
a distinct phenomenon layered
on top of some other effect
of the psychedelic drugs
impacting access to the
unconscious, hallucinations?
In other words, is it the
increased connectivity
that's leading to the
subjective experience,
or are those two things
happening in parallel?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Well,
they happen in parallel
and they map to each other.
But the question of
causality, what causes what,
is the tricky thing
where I would suggest
that the causality is circular.
That they influence each other.
And this gets a
bit philosophical.
But it matters, because
otherwise, there's
a trap that it's easy to fall
into where you're thinking
that it's all about
the brain action
causing the
subjective experience.
And that's typically what we
do in cognitive neuroscience.
It's like the first port of
call materialist approach.
But one can be a materialist,
essentially, but still
appreciate that circular
causality that mind also
interacts with brain.
And it's so hard to
pick the two apart.
And there is a kind
of essential dualism
where subjective experience
is a thing in and of itself.
But that's not to
divorce it from what's
going on the biological level.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
The reason I ask
is because as I understand
it, nowadays, there's
a bit of a movement within
the scientific community
that studies psychedelics
to develop drugs that can,
essentially, cure
or alleviate many
of the symptoms of
depression or trauma
that are built off our
understanding of how
psychedelics like psilocybin and
here I'll throw MDMA in there,
although classically not a
psychedelic, it gets lumped in.
We can get back to that later.
But that do not
produce hallucinations
or massive changes in
subjective experience.
Actually, I think this
is what initially got us
into conversation
on Twitter as I
had learned about this
paper published out
of a group at UC Davis.
That essentially
modifying psychedelics
so that they have potential
therapeutic application
for the treatment of
depression but zero
hallucinogenic properties.
And I thought, wow.
This is going to be a
very controversial thing
in the world, right?
Because the history
of psychedelics,
as you pointed out,
has been one of people
accessing different modes
of thinking, feeling.
Seeing things and letting go.
Trust, et cetera.
A therapeutic relationship.
And here we have--
I don't want to say pharma
because it's not really pharma,
but we have laboratories who
are trying to tease apart
the activation of receptors
independent of all
that subjective
experience in order
to, essentially, treat
the same conditions.
I'd love for you to
comment on this, where
you think it might be going.
And whether or not
you think that's
the right or the wrong approach,
if it has any validity at all.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It is
pharmas, just smaller pharma,
sort of startup pharma.
But--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: OK.
So because pharma
would like to have
drugs that can cure depression
but don't make people
hallucinate.
Is that correct?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Oh, they would.
And patients might
and the system
would love it, because
the system is used to it.
It's medicine.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right.
And it doesn't give this mental
imagery of the Summer of Love
in San Francisco or of
kaleidoscope eyes, right?
It's more of--
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You
can imagine, the more--
I have to be careful
with my wording here.
Those who would not be
inclined toward that
might embrace a therapeutic
that is strictly
effective at treating depression
with no hallucinations.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And it doesn't look like an
individual lying on a sofa
crying their eyes out about
the life that they've lived.
And that deep catharsis
being life-transforming.
Is very different
from that model.
I'm skeptical of it
for a few reasons.
And one is that I
can't see the logic--
I can't see the pieces fit
in a way that's compelling.
And I'm also skeptical,
because I think it could easily
be wishful thinking, because
of that point that patients
would like it and the
system would like it.
And you got to bear
that in mind as well.
So wouldn't it be
convenient if it were true
and you could get the
therapeutic action
without the psychedelic effects?
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Well, in a way, that's
a little bit of what microdosing
seems to be designed to do.
Like you said, take dosages
that are below that perceptual
or awareness of some
effect threshold
over a longer period of time in
an attempt to ping the circuits
or alter the circuits
but not hallucinate.
Not have a catharsis.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: So
if microdosing can do that,
and it's sub-perceptible,
then microdosing
isn't a psychedelic
action, because whereas
the psychedelic action.
When psychedelic, when defined,
means psyche revealing.
You're not getting that effect.
You might be getting
the pharmacology,
you might be getting some
direct serotonin to a receptor
agonism that could be driving
a therapeutic response,
but you can get that
with SSRIs as well.
And so my point is, what's new?
OK.
Maybe it's a bit new
and people are now
developing direct 2A
agonists rather than indirect
through a serotonin releaser
like the selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors,
the SSRIs like Lexapro.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Are there any SSRIs
that selectively agonize,
which folks by the way means,
activate, in a good way.
Agony sounds terrible.
Those not informed might
think that mean that disrupt.
But that can activate the
serotonin 2A receptor.
Are there any drugs that will
do that are not psychedelic?
I'm not aware of any,
but then again I'm
not a psychopharmacologist.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, there are.
I mean, are there any
that are licensed and used
as medicines in psychiatry?
I actually had this debate
recently on social media,
and I couldn't see a
compelling example.
I saw 2A agonists that
were used for other things.
You have a compound
like Lesuride
used in treating Parkinson's,
but actually it's
more of a dopamine agonist.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right.
So they're always hitting
other things, right?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
They're always tapping
other neurotransmitters--
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: All that
being used for other things.
So is there a
selective serotonin
2A receptor
stimulator, an agonist,
that isn't psychedelic, that
is therapeutic in psychiatry
and the answer firmly is, no.
I haven't seen it yet.
Will they develop one?
Well, for patients
sake, I hope so.
Because it would be great.
Let's wait and see.
If they do, I doubt
it'll be psychedelic
and I doubt it would have much
to do with psychedelic therapy.
And it would be much more
like the system we're used to
of chronic pharmacotherapy.
Take your drug every day.
Let's hope they find it and
it works for patients sake.
But as things stand right
now, I'm a little skeptical.
Now, some of the
findings that are
being seen that are
really exciting, fantastic
work being done, showing
things like increases
in the communication
components of neurons,
dendritic growth, spine
growth, synaptic spine growth.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
by the way, folks,
just I'll interrupt for
not necessarily spine--
not the cerebral
column but spines
are these little
tiny twigs with bulbs
on the end of neurons that
allow for communication
points between neurons.
So neuroplasticity
is often associated
with growth of
dendrites and spines
and so forth, which is
what Robin's referring to.
That reminds me, and I
just want to make sure
that we close the hatch
on the earlier answer,
because I interrupted you.
Is the increased
connectivity between--
or communication
between brain areas
that's observed while people
are under the influence
of the psychedelic
also observed later
after the effects of
the drug wear off?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And then I'll just
throw in another question there,
because we're on to this topic
now.
To what extent do we think that
neuroplasticity, structural
changes in neurons,
functional changes in neurons
are responsible for that?
And how long does that last?
Let's say I come
into your clinic,
I'm a subject in your
experiment, I take--
come in the morning, I
do my psychedelic journey
five or six hours later.
I'm parachuting back to
reality, as we call it,
and then I go home.
Increase connectivity
lasts for how long,
and how long are the structural
brain changes occurring?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, you're
asking fantastic questions,
and partly because we
don't have the answer yet.
But we do have some data.
And so we have looked
at, first of all,
in a sense, the functional
plasticity of what we assume
it to be or at
least the functional
changes, the increase in
communication across systems
that increase in
global connectivity,
functional connectivity.
Do we see it after the trip?
We know we see it during the
trip pretty well replicated
correlating with
intense drug effects.
Do we see it after the trip?
Well the answer
is, we've seen it
in two different depression
cohorts, psilocybin therapy
for depression.
In one study where we looked
the next day, we saw it.
A kind of residual effect
similar to what you see acutely
being seen the next day.
And then in a
subsequent study, we
saw it also three weeks later.
So we've seen it in two
independent data sets.
This decrease in modularity
is how we measure it.
It's the same
thing, essentially.
Broadly speaking,
it's the same thing.
An increase in
global connectivity,
functional connectivity.
And actually,
unpublished we've seen it
in healthy volunteers on
a correlational level.
Not on an absolute
change level, but if you
look at its relationship
to a mental health outcome,
and this is an important thing
to stress with the depression
work, we saw a relationship
between the magnitude
of that change, the decrease
in modularity or increase
in global connectivity,
and the improvement
in symptom severity.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So interesting.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And just
to state it a different way,
so what Robin is referring to
is when you say modularity,
as neuroscientists, we think of
the different modular networks
of the brain.
The eye talks to a region
of the thalamus involved
in vision, which talks to the
visual cortex, which eventually
converges with auditory
information, of course.
But there's a separation
or modularity of function.
This increased connectivity
is cross-modular
in during the trip,
but afterwards as well.
And you're saying that that
correlates very strongly
with the strength of
the therapeutic outcome
for depression.
I mean, the logical
extension of that
is that extreme modularity
of brain function
is depressive in some way.
Now, we don't want
to go too far,
but what does that
mean that increasing
crosstalk between different
modules of the brain
is so strongly correlated with
a positive therapeutic outcome?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
We don't other
than there's a relationship.
I mean, this is the thing.
We need to be a little careful
not to run with it too far.
I mean, there's some
things that it suggests.
I think it suggests a more
flexible mode of brain
functioning, if you're not
getting stuck in modules
or the modules
aren't excessively
cut off from each other.
But you see different things
with different presentations
if you were to
look at cognition.
Sharper cognition is
actually associated
with more modularity.
So it's a rule that's
a little slippery.
And we need to be
careful with it.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Again,
forgive me for interrupting,
but I think I have
friends who are--
I would say, are
on the spectrum.
Who are very linear
in their thinking
and extremely
intelligent in the kind
of classic sense of
being able to ratchet
through hard problems
to arrive at a solution.
And then I have
friends who are-- let's
just call them what they are.
From the creative communities
outside of science
that are very expansive,
they see connections
between many different
things, but sometimes, you
have to-- not all
of them, but you
have to catch their ideas
with a butterfly net.
And oftentimes, what
they're saying sometimes
it just doesn't make any sense.
Now, they also produce
incredible creative works.
But to have a
conversation with them
is anything but a
linear experience.
They are not random
thought generators,
but there's a non-linearity or
randomness to their processing
that's distinct from
these other folks
that I'm describing
on the spectrum.
And of course, it's a spectrum.
There's a whole
range in between.
It sounds to me like there
is some therapeutic value
to being able to move along
this continuum from the more
linear to the nonlinear.
Is that correct?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, I think so.
Yeah.
It's resonating
what you're saying.
It's speaking to my intuition.
That you could be very
passy, passing things up,
chopping things up like an
analytical scientist like I'm
doing a bit.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: A splitter
as we say in science.
You're either a
lumper or a splitter.
Yeah.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
The way I'm
being very particular about when
to call something psychedelic.
That kind of passy analytical
way of thinking you
might associate with
a more modular system.
Whereas the system that's
more globally, interconnected,
and open, yeah.
Might be more flexible
and creative and divergent
in the associations
and so on so.
Yes.
That's speaking to my intuition
to how you're describing it.
And I imagine, if you take
severe psychopathology, severe
mental illness
like a depression,
I've always thought that
there's something intuitive
about the term itself.
Like a depression in a
landscape, which is a halt.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Physical depression.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
A physical depression
that is easy to fall into.
And if you do, it's
hard to get out of.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So almost--
if I understand what
you're saying correctly,
almost like getting stuck at
one location on this continuum.
Because most people don't
reside at one extreme
or the other full time.
They can kind of
migrate back and forth
between expansive states
and more linear states.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Like you do with low mood.
If you're "healthy"
in inverted commas,
you can feel your low
mood, your disappointment.
But you can spring back.
But someone with--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And you
know you can spring back.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right.
Whereas the suicidal
depressive person or suicidally
depressed person, somehow,
at least in my understanding,
there's something about that
extreme depressive states
and extreme anxiety states,
something my laboratory is
a bit more familiar
with anxiety, which
alters the perception of
time such that people feel
like that negative state
is going to go on forever
or that if it goes away, that
it's going to return at random.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Kind
of a vulnerability
to the time domain.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
And it's so tragic, that
cognitive bias in depression
that everything's
hopeless and that there
is no light at the
end of the tunnel.
Yeah.
Yes.
So if you were to get stuck in
that rut and have that bias,
then you're cut off
from other things,
other sensory
modalities or modules,
cut off from the world,
cut off from other people.
Stuck in your inner rut.
So yes.
I think we're sharing
this intuition
that a decrease in
modularity or an opening
up of the system, the brain
could relate to an opening
up of the mind that is enduring
after the psychedelic dosing
session.
And yeah.
And the third replication
was to see in healthies
an improvement in well-being.
Because they're healthy, we
don't look at depression.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So these are people
that are healthy
walking into the trial?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Take
psilocybin twice?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, actually they do.
But the first dose is
1 milligram, which they
don't feel it's a placebo dose.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Quote
unquote, "micro dose."
Yeah.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
We stick EGG on their heads
to measure their brainwaves
during each dose.
And 1 milligram,
you see no change.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I think
that, you microdosers.
No, I'm just kidding.
I mean, nothing against
the micro doses.
I've always just been
a little bit skeptical
based on my conversations
with the scientists
actually doing the
work with psychedelics.
It seems like the answer
keeps coming back.
1 or 2, maybe 3 macro doses
in a controlled safe setting.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, that's compelling.
The evidence for
that is compelling.
And that's what's making all
the difference right now.
Microdosing is just
appealing, but again,
science isn't about
what we want to believe,
it's about what's
actually coming through
and what seems to
hold up to testing.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd like
to just take a brief break
and thank one of our
sponsors, which is LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need
and nothing you don't.
That means, plenty of salt--
sodium, magnesium,
and potassium,
the so-called
electrolytes and no sugar.
Now, salt, magnesium,
and potassium
are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body,
in particular, to the function
of your nerve cells, also
called neurons.
And we now know that
even slight reductions
in electrolyte concentrations
or dehydration of the body
can lead to deficits in
cognitive and physical
performance.
LMNT contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio
of 1,000 milligrams, that's 1
gram of sodium, 200 milligrams
of potassium, and 60
milligrams of magnesium.
I typically drink LMNT
first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order
to hydrate my body
and make sure I have
enough electrolytes.
And while I do any kind
of physical training
and after physical training
as well, especially,
if I've been sweating
a lot and certainly,
I drink LMNT in my water
when I'm in the sauna
and after going in the
sauna, because that
causes quite a lot of sweating.
If you'd like to try LMNT
you can go to drinklmnt--
that's L-M-N-T.com/huberman to
claim a free LMNT sample pack
with your purchase.
Again, that's drinklmnt--
L-M-N-T.com/huberman.
Would you say that's right?
That one or two or three
sessions, and how far
apart are those
typically spaced in time?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Typically, one to three
weeks across the sites
is the way people are doing
the psychedelic therapy
dosing sessions.
Two sessions, you know,
Hopkins, Imperial, NYU.
That's been a kind
of default to--
we actually use three
in a current anorexia
trial, psilocybin
therapy for anorexia.
Two patients left
to see after 19
who've gone through the trial.
Very exciting results there.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You're
seeing an alleviation
of the obsessive thought
about food and a willingness
to consume healthier
amounts of food.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Even improved weight
at the long follow-up.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So critical.
When we did an episode
on eating disorders,
I learned that anorexia
nervosa, which by the way folks,
the rates are not increasing.
It's been pretty
stable through time
despite what's said about
social media, and et cetera.
But anorexia nervosa
being the most
deadly of all
psychiatric illnesses,
which is a big statement,
because manic depression,
so-called bipolar depression,
has a 20 to 30 times
the typical suicide rate.
Basically, many people with
anorexia, I think is how it's--
is what one says, not anorexics.
But people with
anorexia often die.
Many of them die.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
So tragic.
So often young people as well.
And similarly, with suicide
in terms of premature death.
So the tragedy with
psychiatry is so strong.
It's so rewarding to
be doing that trial
and to be seeing good results.
I have to check
myself a little bit
that I'm reporting on it in
this really promisory way
and the trial isn't yet
publicly released and published.
So it's still ongoing as well.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: But
that was three sessions.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
It is three sessions.
And I can't say what the dosage
is, because we still have--
there is a blinding component.
But there are three
dosing sessions in there.
Let's see now.
I think they're two weeks
apart and we do the follow-up.
Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd
like to close out
this description of the
journey and the trip
by extending past the
day when people actually
take the drug into this--
what I've described
as the integration phase.
You have to re-integrate.
All this increased connectivity
during the session.
Hallucinations, insights,
anxiety, letting go.
Maybe revelation,
maybe epiphany.
OK.
Great.
At what point is
that consolidated?
Meaning, are these
patients or subjects
in studies having
daily conversation
with their therapist?
Are they journaling every day?
And I want to keep in mind
that most people are not going
to be part of a clinical trial.
And of course, here
we're not suggesting
what people do or not do.
But let's just put it this way.
Were people to use psychedelics,
what is the way that people can
maximize on the neuroplasticity
and the brain changes
in a positive way in the
days and weeks afterwards?
In other words, how long does
this so-called integration
last?
And how far can we take this?
I mean, I could imagine
that how often one
chooses to think
about the insights
could also have an impact.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right?
Because clearly people
went to raves, clearly
people did psychedelics
in the '60s.
We don't know if clearly
people do psychedelics now.
But we don't have
data on those people.
You have access to the
understanding of how they're
spending their time and
the therapeutic outcomes,
which we haven't gotten to
the numbers yet, but again,
are incredibly impressive.
In upwards of, as
I understand it,
60% or more people getting
relief from depression.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
70%, yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: 70%.
Incredible, especially
when compared
to the typical antidepressant
treatments and so on.
So what is this
business of integration?
How is it done properly?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
Gosh.
Well, how long does
it last as well?
A lifetime?
You know?
Life is a journey like
a trip is a journey.
And there's always work to do.
As Jack Kornfield says, after
the, ecstasy the laundry.
And you know?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I love that.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
There'll be other good ones
as well, but forget them.
But yeah.
So the work is
ongoing, and yeah.
But this gives you a foot up.
It enables people to do the work
more easily, and that's true.
The classic psychedelics
is also true.
Very true of MDMA therapy for
post-traumatic stress disorder.
It's really giving you a
leg up, making it easier
to do very, very difficult
work going back to a trauma.
Trying to digest it,
process it, integrate it.
So it's such an
essential component
of the treatment model.
But one has to be realistic
as well by saying, oh,
integration lasts a lifetime.
Well, people
delivering a service
can't be there for a lifetime.
So what's the answer there?
And people are wrestling
with that issue right now.
And I think one of the solutions
might be that it's, in a sense,
on you to appoint.
The therapeutic team
can treat you to a point
and then it becomes what
you might call practice.
In a similar way, that
meditation is a practice.
It's something that
you have to keep up.
And if it slips, then
things could slip.
And that's the way it is.
Or you have another
psychedelic treatment.
So people have even used
this term of practice
in relation to
psychedelics, where
there's a psychedelic practice
like there's a meditation
practice.
But I'm using meditation
intentionally here because they
actually think that
meditative practice, elements
of spiritual practice could
be a very important complement
to psychedelic therapy.
And I think it's probably
doing something similar
in terms of promoting
an ability to sit with--
a former colleague of
mine said it quite well.
In relation to
psychedelic therapy
versus chronic
pharmacotherapy or like SSRIs
being on them all the time.
Says psychedelic
therapy allows you
to sit with rather than sit on.
And so that's quite good.
Yeah.
So the meditation, the
mindfulness, the ability to,
yes, be present-centered
but also present-centered
and accepting so
if things come up,
you can watch and
process and then let go.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That
Holy Grail of mindfulness.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Awareness
without reactivity, respond.
I grew up in the
Bay Area and you'd
hear this language, right?
And I'm not being
disparaging this.
I have friends that are on
the board of Esalen and work
down there.
And I've gone there.
And yet you hear
these terms, right?
Be responsive, not reactive,
which to a neuroscientist
is like grates on me,
which probably just means
I have issues.
And surely, I do.
But what does that mean?
It's saying like, oh,
to be the observer
but not be drawn
into the experience.
And again, I don't want
to be overly reductionist,
but what I find so compelling
about the emerging data,
because it really is data,
on psychedelics as treatments
for depression and trauma,
namely psilocybin and MDMA
is that it really seems to
allow people this space that
is so commonly thrown around.
Giving space between
stimulus and reaction.
Viktor Frankl talked about this.
But I've been reading
a wonderful book
called The Prince of Medicine.
Dates back to the
origins of medicine.
Very dense book.
People have been
talking about this stuff
and thinking about this
stuff for thousands of years.
Psychedelics seem to give people
access to that better version
of self, which is remarkable.
What's also remarkable, it's,
perhaps, worth pointing out
is that, five years
ago, I never would
have been comfortable
having this conversation.
I would have been
afraid to lose my job.
Stanford Magazine, this week,
just published an entire issue
about psychedelics with
how ketamine works, MDMA,
psilocybin with the appropriate
cautionary notes in there.
But clearly, times are changing.
Speaking of which, I know you're
doing a trial on first-time use
of psychedelics.
What inspired that?
And what are you observing?
And as you tell us
that, please give us
a few of the key contours.
What's the dose, how
old are these subjects?
I'm assuming it's men, women.
Are they suffering
from depression or not?
What's the landscape
of that study?
And I realize this is still
early days of the study
or maybe it's close
to completion.
It's not yet published,
however, correct?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It's not
published, it's not submitted,
it is completed.
So this was another one of
our COVID studies, in a sense,
meaning COVID hit and we
had to finish the study.
And it was hard to finish
the study because of COVID.
That was true of our psilocybin
therapy versus escitalopram.
Lexapro trial, which is
published in The New England
Journal of Medicine.
But the--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: This was '20--
that paper, by the way, folks,
we'll provide a link to
in the show note captions
as well as some of
Robin's other papers.
I think the 2022 New England
Journal paper is really
fabulous given the different
dosages and the comparison
to, essentially,
what is microdosing
and the comparison
to citalopram.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
Yeah.
That's interesting
that you link the way
we gave small doses of
psilocybin to microdosing.
We didn't think of it that way.
We thought it was just
a necessary placebo
for the big dose,
the 25 milligrams.
Yeah.
So that we could say to everyone
we're giving you psilocybin
and not be lying.
Yeah.
For those who got escitalopram,
Lexapro for six weeks,
they got a very, very
low dose of psilocybin.
But it allowed us to standardize
all the psychotherapy and so
on.
But the other study
that you're referring to
was in healthy volunteers.
Middle-aged.
Average age, I think, was 40.
So not your typical
student study
that is so often the case
in psychology research.
All the undergrads end up
volunteering for your study.
So this is more of an
age range and also--
I think it was an equal
proportion of male and female.
All the staff
actually were female,
which the staff were
very proud of them.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Although,
it produces its own potential
confound, right?
To become all one sex of staff.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Possibly.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: They
did a good job in the sense
that we saw significant
improvements in well-being
at the end of the trial.
So let me describe the design.
It was a repeated measures
design, meaning people come in,
you collect your baseline
data and do a brain scan,
and you give people a placebo.
We gave people a placebo.
And actually let me
rewind a little bit.
Everyone's healthy volunteers,
middle-aged never taken
a psychedelic in their life.
None of them.
Entirely fresh, virgin
people coming in.
And the plan is to give them
their first ever psychedelic
experience.
So that's what we
did in this study.
But to do it, we have this
repeated measures design where
they'll first get a placebo.
And we have the
placebo so that we
can do all the procedures,
all the therapy, all the music
listening but not give a
whopping dose of psilocybin.
Again, we gave them a
placebo dose of psilocybin.
1 milligram.
We stick EEG headsets
on during the experience
to record the brain activity
from the scalp, the oscillating
electrical activity.
And we do the MRI scanning
before and after to see deeper
into the brain, and we can look
at the functional connectivity
that we were referring to
earlier, and also properties
of brain anatomy, which
we did in this study.
So the short story is that
all of the changes that we
saw both psychologically
and neurobiologically
were seen with
the 25 milligrams.
It all happened with
that big whopping dose.
And what did we see?
Well, we did see
significant improvements
in psychological well-being.
We saw what I call the entropic
brain effect, which is actually
formerly quite accurate.
We see an increase in the
informational complexity
of ongoing brain activity
recorded with the EEG
on the dose of psilocybin.
The activity becomes
more complex.
It's harder to
predict across time.
It's more informationally rich.
And that effect
correlates as it does
very reliably with the magnitude
of the subjective effect.
So the bigger the trip, the
bigger this entropic brain
effect.
Now, pretty well
replicated finding.
But then the MRI, seeing
deep into the brain
was probably our
most exciting result
where we didn't just see some
functional brain changes,
but we've seen some anatomical
brain changes as well.
And we used a technique called
diffusion tensor imaging that
looks at the cabling of the
brain, the white matter tracts.
And we saw a change
in major tracts.
So we limited our search
space to really thick tracts.
Really thick fibers.
And the fibers that
came through as changing
were ones that traveled
between the prefrontal cortex
and the thalamus
and the striatum.
There were two tracks, two
prefrontal tracks that changed.
And they changed in the
direction of a decrease
in axial diffusivity,
which could be interpreted
as tract integrity where
a decrease would be
an increase in tract integrity.
It is something that you
see in the developing brain.
The axial diffusivity
decreases as the brain goes
from being a baby
to being an adult.
Axial diffusivity goes down.
And then in aging and
pathologies of aging,
axial diffusivity goes up.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: This is
in the opposite direction
of the results you talked
about earlier in terms
of brain connectivity
of increased
communication across areas.
If I understand
correctly, and I'm
perfectly happy to be wrong,
by the way, that this decrease
in axial diffusivity
translates to a higher
fidelity of communication
between the prefrontal cortex
and the thalamus and
striatum as opposed to less.
And your description
of this as somewhat
like the transition from
babyhood and childhood
to adulthood.
Speaks to the same where
we know that there's
a massive culling of
connections as opposed
to growth of connections.
So in other words,
as we get older,
we get better at
doing certain things
and less good at doing
potentially most everything
else.
Is that right?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Ish.
Because the change was
anatomical and not functional.
So the other stuff was is
really measuring communication
in the brain by looking at
how the activity fluctuates
across time and whether those
fluctuations in activity
are synchronous between regions.
And if they are, we say
they're functionally connected.
And we infer that they're
talking to each other,
because they go up
and down in synchrony.
But when it comes
to the anatomy,
we're talking about the
just static material stuff.
And so we're seeing the fibers
and a property of the fibers
change.
At least that's what we think.
And recently, we had
an independent person
come in and reanalyze the data,
because one of those things,
incredible finding
requires credible evidence,
really strong evidence.
And I would say, the evidence
at the moment is one study.
So we need to be
cautious on that.
But we did re-analyze it
and use this correction
procedure-free water correction
to be more sure that it
was a change in the
actual microstructure
rather than something to do
with the extracellular space.
The water surrounding
the fibers.
And it came through.
In fact, the change
was strengthened
by doing this correction step.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
this is neuroplasticity
as the consequence of one
first time session with 25
milligrams of psilocybin.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
So we're excited and the two--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Understandably so.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: --the two
different-- the second analyst
coming in wasn't
sure she believed it
and then she thought this
correction technique might
kill the result and then it came
through, and she's like, OK.
Now, I'm excited too.
So we'll see.
We don't know what it means.
What does it mean functionally?
We don't know.
How did the people change?
Well, psychologically, as I
said, well-being improved.
We did look at their
cognition, and we
used a cognitive
flexibility paradigm that
looks at people's ability
to notice a rule change
and then flexibly adapt their
behavior based on noticing
this rule change and people
improved after the 25
milligrams and didn't
significantly improve
after the placebo dose.
There weren't correlations with
the DTI change, the cabling
change and these
psychological outcomes.
But with these studies
and smaller sample sizes,
you don't always see those
correlations come through.
So it's something.
We don't know what it means.
But it's a change
in brain anatomy
that's in the opposite
direction to what
you see in an aging brain
or with pathology of aging.
And it's what you see
in a healthy brain
as it goes from normal
neurodevelopment
into adulthood.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Very, very
exciting and intriguing.
And I appreciate
that you highlighted
that it's just one study,
although from everything you've
said, it sounds like it's
been done with immense rigor.
So we will eagerly await the
publication of that study
so we can peruse all the data
and the subsequent studies.
I want to hear a
bit about the study
that you have been carrying
out on the use of psilocybin
for the treatment
of fibromyalgia.
I'm intrigued by
fibromyalgia, because I
have a good friend who also--
I won't reveal who it is.
No.
It's not me.
This isn't the "I
have a friend thing."
Who also is a scientist who
sits at a fairly high position
in the National Institutes
of Health who quietly
has expressed to me
that they are incredibly
frustrated with the fact that
the standard medical community
has largely ignored
fibromyalgia.
And that for many years, it was
lumped with things like chronic
fatigue syndrome and
other so-called--
again, so-called.
I'm not saying this.
But people often
refer to these as, oh.
It's psychosomatic.
That's all in your head.
Which, as a neuroscientist, is
a ridiculous statement to hear,
because it's all in your head.
Your brain is in
your head after all.
Your physiology
and your psychology
are influencing each other.
Of course.
And the world is starting
to appreciate that more.
But first of all,
maybe you could
tell people what
fibromyalgia is,
what inspired you to do
a study on fibromyalgia
using psilocybin of all
things because that's
surprising to me.
And if you are allowed
to or if you have access
to the data in
mind, share with us
a little bit about what you're
discovering in that study.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Sure.
Yeah.
Happy to.
So again, it's psilocybin
therapy and the population
is fibromyalgia syndrome.
So this is people
presenting with
a generalized chronic pain.
So unlike some
other pain disorders
where the pain is focused.
You can say, it's my lower
back, which is very common.
Chronic lower back pain.
This is more generalized.
And for that reason, it's
hard to know what it is.
And that's why it's been a
controversial space in medicine
and it's been-- yeah.
It's had that charge thrown
at it that maybe it's
psychosomatic, and
just to your point,
is anything ever independent
of the mind, anyway.
But this is actually
a fascinating space
for how subjective experience,
the lived experience,
and the mind can
influence the body.
Because there's some really
interesting literature
around the etiology.
How the pain has come about.
In a sense like what
caused the pain.
What's the story there?
And the head of the trial, I
would say to my colleagues,
let's just be careful.
Because there is some
fascinating literature
around things like a
background of trauma
and how that can relate to
issues related to inflammation
and how that can
express into things
like fibromyalgia syndrome.
I just said, be
very careful there,
because if you go in
with an assumption
that there's some buried
trauma, for example,
then there's that
whole other side
of psychoanalysis that
massively tripped it up
around false memory and so on.
And so please don't
hold prior assumptions
that you're going to uncover
buried trauma in every case.
Now, the team of
treated, I think,
eight people and it
is going very well.
Again, I just want to
be careful with how
I describe it to manage
expectations and not
get too carried away.
But I check in with
the team every week,
and they're still based
in London doing the work.
And it's remarkable what I hear
about the profound experiences
that people have under the drug.
In this study, we
only give one dose.
It's a very mechanistic study.
We actually have the EEG
cap on in the sessions
like in the healthy
volunteer study,
but this time now taking it
into a clinical population.
And--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So they
are wearing an eye mask
under the influence of 25
milligrams of psilocybin.
Most of them probably have
not done psilocybin before.
So it's a little bit like the
first time study in some sense.
They have fibromyalgia that's
debilitating in some way.
They don't want it, obviously.
And during the session, are
they thinking about their pain?
Are they being told to
think about their pain?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
They're not
being told to think
about the pain.
In fact, as I understand it,
while there is a therapeutic
model around acceptance
of the pain, it isn't--
unlike some of
the PTSD work, you
aren't encouraging them to
focus on the index trauma
and then work through it
and try and digest it.
We don't do that with the pain.
So the pain is there, but
there isn't an invitation
to focus on it.
And that's probably
one of the differences
with classic psychedelic
therapy versus MDMA therapy.
Arguably, MDMA therapy is
more like it's a bit closer
to traditional talk therapy
where there is more dialogue.
People are able to talk on MDMA.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: In
the MDMA trials, do you
know whether or not
they used eye masks or--
because this seems to be
an important distinction
between, as you described,
the therapeutic trip
versus the trip that one
does going into the woods
and taking psilocybin in
the woods or at a party
or while staring at
a poster or a leaf.
Again, I'm not trying to
trivialize those experiences.
I mean, obviously,
they can be profound.
So I'm told.
But the MDMA trials
seem to involve,
as you said, more
directed dialogue.
And sometimes, even
empathic connection
between people by
they're actually
looking at one another,
the eyes and eye contact
being such a key part of
the human social cognitive
connective networks.
So do you know if they
put eye masks on people
during the therapeutic session?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
I'm pretty sure that they
have the eye masks there.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Right.
Because a lot of
the MDMA work, and I
was part of an MDMA trial.
Was, as I understand
geared toward developing,
because it's an empathogen
empathy toward the self.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure they
have the eye masks there,
but they probably-- and
it's a great question,
because you could
formally test this.
It probably don't
use them as much.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Mhm.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: The
thing is with the classic
psychedelics, if you're
looking at your guides
or your facilitators and
their faces are melting or--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
On MDMA, you just
might really start to feel
more connected to you.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
They might look especially
beautiful and you know--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: sure.
Yeah.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: And yeah.
There's that fascinating
effect of loving the people
that you're with.
And so yeah.
I imagine they talk more
and use the eye shades less.
And it is more interpersonal
rather than like intrapersonal
or going inside.
They do use a
fascinating terminology
that some people have critiqued,
but it is a very interesting
phenomenon.
And it's this notion
of the inner healer.
They use that language a lot.
It's been critiqued because
it sounds very suggestive.
You know?
And that's probably one
of the vehicles here.
Driving the therapeutic
process is suggestion.
I think we have to
be honest about that.
So when they go inside,
that's another term
that we use very much in the
classic psychedelic therapy
work.
You go inside.
You put the eyeshades
on, and people
are encouraged to go inside.
But when they do that
in the MDMA work,
especially, they might
be told explicitly
and listen to the inner
healer and that language.
So you could see how
a cynic or a skeptic
could come in and see that as
some kind of like suggestive
priming or biasing.
I think they have a point.
Skeptics often do, but I don't
think it's all of the story.
And just briefly, because
it's an interesting point,
speaking to that point
a bit in our psilocybin
therapy versus
escitalopram trial,
we measured
pre-trial expectancy.
And we did it for
both conditions.
So what kind of
improvement do you
expect with the Lexapro,
the escitalopram
at the end of the trial?
And what kind of improvement if
you go into the psilocybin arm
and get two big
doses of psilocybin.
What kind of improvement do you
think you'll see in that arm?
And of course, it
was a coin flip
as to what arm people went into
and there was no crossover.
What we found was that it was
true that we had a sample bias,
so most people had higher
expectation stations.
On average, there were higher
expectations for psilocybin
and its efficacy
or effectiveness
versus the SSRI, the Lexapro.
However, when we looked
at the correlation
or the predictive relationship
between pre-trial expectancy
and response, we saw
that pre-trial expectancy
for the escitalopram
predicted response
to escitalopram across virtually
every single measure, all
these different measures
of depression and anxiety
and well-being, and I
think none of the scales.
I'm pretty sure it was none of
about 12 or so mental health
rating scales.
Was there a relationship
between pre-trial expectancy?
Even though it was high,
it didn't predict--
pre-trial expectancy
didn't predict response
to the psilocybin therapy.
So that was a bit of a smash
on the head for the idea
that the classic
psychedelic therapy is
some kind of placebo response.
And I think it's so important
to address that question.
Because if it
doesn't come through
as it didn't come
through, then it
opens up even more intrigue
about, well, what is it then?
If it's not just a placebo
response or a super placebo
response like an amplification
of the placebo response,
then it must be something else.
And how intriguing?
It has a direct
therapeutic action.
It must be something.
And we don't yet
know what it is.
I talked about the
residual increase
in global connectivity.
That's one possibility.
But the truth is, we're
just scratching the surface.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And yet
the therapeutic outcomes
are, again, just so
marvelously impressive.
I'm curious as to why as--
well, there are that many labs.
But the laboratories that are
focused on classic psychedelics
for the treatment of
depression and now as you
mentioned, promising results
for anorexia and fibromyalgia
as well.
Although preliminary
very promising.
Why the lack of
attention toward LSD?
Is it that the LSD
trips are just too long?
Is it that they are
qualitatively different?
Are there any data on
non-microdoses of LSD?
And here I want to
be very careful,
because I learned through my
interactions on social media
that this term microdose
is very misleading.
And in some cases, can be
dangerously misleading,
because, as you
mentioned earlier,
the effective
psychedelic dose or the--
effective meaning
that can induce
a real trip with hallucinations,
et cetera, of LSD
is actually in the
microgram range.
So some people hear microdose,
and they think microgram of LSD
is a-- micrograms is a
microdose when, in fact,
a macrodose of LSD can be
measured in micrograms, right?
So this is where in the
absence of scientific training,
people can really go astray.
Or even just in lack
of understanding
of the metric system.
And since now you're a
recent arrival to the US,
fortunate for us.
Sorry.
England's loss is
the US's gain by--
Robbins Lab moved from England
to the United States recently.
So score 1 for us.
But why isn't there more
use of LSD in these trials?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
I think it probably
is the duration of the trip.
It used to be stigma
and it was easier
to get your psilocybin
study through,
because others were, they
were getting that through.
So there was the likes of
Franz Vollenweider in Zurich
in Switzerland and
then Roland Griffiths
coming along and doing the
psilocybin work at Hopkins.
So you could appeal
to that precedence
and say, well, they're
doing it over there.
Can we not do it
in little England?
So that's how it worked for us.
We did actually go on
and do an LSD study
once we'd laid the foundations
for doing this kind of work.
And it was a brain
imaging study.
It was a really
extensive one actually
where we used both MRI
and another modality
called MEG, sort of
super EEG in a sense.
But you know, why didn't
that turn our heads
to think, oh, should we not
be doing our trials with LSD?
It does have something
to do with the pragmatics
like a study day with
psilocybin is long enough.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
four to six-hour trip?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And the FDA asked us to
have the people in the lab
until eight hours post-dose,
which personally I think
could be quite excessive,
especially if it's a low dose.
And if you have that in the
placebo condition as well,
it becomes impractical.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
Scientists are not
paid nearly enough
to warrant the-- there's
no such thing as overtime
for the graduate
students and postdocs.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
It's often those
more junior members
that are doing that
really hard work.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It was
described very well to me
by a student when I was-- a
graduate student said to me,
they really can't afford
to pay us by the hour.
Because we used to work.
He was a electrophysiologist,
so he would run experiments.
No joke, folks.
Three to five-day experiments.
Sleeping in bouts of
two hours here or there
in a dark room with a bunch
of equipment and recordings.
So these are long, long
acute electrophysiological
recordings.
So yeah.
No scientist does it for
the money, I promise you.
There is money in
pharma, there is not
money in personal income.
It's not lucrative for
the basic scientist.
So yes.
LSD is what?
Anywhere from 8 to 15
hours, something like that.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
15 would be a little long.
You'd be a bit worried
if you were still
tripping at that time, maybe
with a really big dose.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oops.
No.
Just kidding.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Eight hours plus-- and
dose dependent, yeah.
If it's a bigger dose,
it's a longer experience.
But if you're going
to dose say, 10:00 AM
in the morning, which is more
or less how it often goes, then
that's 6:00 PM still
feeling the effects.
And then how long do you
wait now to close things out
before they can go home.
Even with psilocybin, you
have people still at work
into the evening.
And the staff are
always there later,
of course, because they've
got to pack up and yeah.
So these are long days.
And it's too much, you know?
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
That makes sense.
Practical constraints.
I learned from a recent
guest on this podcast
that we recorded with,
Dr. Satchin Panda who
is a colleague of mine when I
was down at the Salk Institute.
Pioneered a lot
of the studies on
so-called intermittent fasting.
That the reason that the eating
period in these studies--
in animals and now
on humans is 8 hours,
the feeding window
in these studies
is because the graduate student
was going to, otherwise,
lose their relationship.
Because their significant
other says, listen,
you can be in the lab
for 12 hours, that
meant some hours before the
experiment, then 8 hours,
and then some hours afterwards.
But you can't stay
in there longer.
And many people use the
eight-hour feeding window
as a consequence.
So the scientist has to
exist and be carried out
in real-world frame.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It does.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: MDMA is a
little bit shorter, right?
It's about a four to--
it's also about four
to six hours, correct?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
It's kind of similar
to psilocybin.
Yeah.
It is.
And actually, in
the maps work, they
redose after a certain point.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: The booster.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: They have
a booster or optional booster,
yeah.
So there is that.
And now, people
are thinking, well,
even the psilocybin sessions
are long and expensive.
And if you have to have
two staff members there
all the time, that's expensive.
That's where most
of the expense is.
Is in the staffing.
So can we abridge the
experience, make it shorter,
and get away with it, and get
similar therapeutic outcomes?
So there's a lot of
interest in that direction.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
May I ask about--
sorry to interrupt,
but I want to make sure
I don't forget to ask about
combination psilocybin MDMA
therapies.
The reason I ask about this is--
and here, truly
not me, but I know
people who do
self-administered combination
psilocybin and MDMA.
I think I heard this right.
I think it's called
a hippy flip.
There's another one
that involves LSD too.
Again, I'm not suggesting people
do these drug combinations.
But the way it was
described to me
was that the psilocybin,
because it's so serotonergic,
sometimes can be not a downer
but can have a bit of kind
of a murky feel to it.
Some real deep
introspection, sometimes
in the darker realms of one's
psyche depressive thoughts,
et cetera.
Not that it necessarily stays
that way throughout the trip,
but that the MDMA,
because it has
a very strongly serotonergic
but also dopaminergic--
I mean, it has an
amphetamine component.
Cocaine-like, in fact.
If you've ever seen
someone on MDMA,
their pupils are about
the size of a quarters.
For a reason, they're
extreme autonomic arousal
compared to a sedative,
which by the way,
would constrict the pupils.
So they describe the use
of MDMA to balance out
the affect component of it.
What are your thoughts on
combination psilocybin MDMA?
Does this hold any
therapeutic potential?
This is, obviously, backyard
chemistry in the sense
that people are cowboying
this stuff on their own,
which again, I don't
really recommend.
I'd like to see the
science go first,
but I understand this is how
it works in the real world.
Yeah.
What are your thoughts
on combining compounds?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Well, I guess, they're cowboying
it in recreational context,
but also underground therapists
do work with this combo.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's
what I'm referring to.
So I'm not talking about people
partying with this stuff.
I'm talking about there are
thousands now of therapists
that offer psychedelic
therapies illegally,
really, because it's not
legal at least, not in the US,
to possess or sell.
But that are doing this.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So that's
really why I'm asking.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And I think there's
something to be said for--
one has to be careful
with this as a scientist.
But if they're doing
it, are they using
some kind of trial and error?
The same is true, of
course, with longer history
of psychedelic plant
medicine use if by plants, we
include the fungi as well.
So in the extended sense plants.
There will have been
trial and error there.
It might not be as systematic
as the science we do today,
but maybe there's been
a learning process.
And maybe what they
do, they've come
to because they found it works.
So by that principle, I'm
interested in that combination
and whether it does offer
some advantages, maybe,
in certain patients.
One of the buzz
terms in medicine
these days is
precision medicine.
A precision medicine and
personalized medicine.
So maybe there are
certain cases where
introducing say, psilocybin
after the MDMA or the other way
around could offer
some advantages.
And the differences
are interesting.
Psilocybin can get
you to deep places.
Maybe the kernel of your
suffering and major life
experiences and complexes
that are causally
linked to whatever the pathology
that you're presenting with.
But it can do it, sometimes,
quite aggressively.
And if it say, post-traumatic
stress disorder,
it can be overwhelming.
And you can fight it.
And really, it's that.
The resistance is
really challenged,
and they fight back.
And the therapeutic
breakthrough and the progress
isn't happening because
you've agitated the defense
mechanisms.
Whereas what MDMA offers
is something arguably
more directionally reliable
in terms of the valence.
It's more directionally positive
generally, an MDMA experience.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Hard to
have a bad time on MDMA.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: To be
quite blunt, I mean.
But one of the concerns
I had with MDMA,
I've never done
it recreationally.
I have had not and have not
ever done it recreationally.
But when it was done in
this therapeutic setting,
I realized, because there was
a music on at the beginning,
I actually asked
them to turn it off,
because I realized that
the music was becoming
such an attractor
to my attention
that I suddenly was starting
to think about music
and my love of
music, which was not
the focus of the session
that was there for.
And I'm glad that they
did turn the music off,
because the moment
they did, I was
able to drop in within the eye
mask to this sort of go inward
and address some certain
issues that at least to me
felt key and productive.
So that seems to be the
kind of hazard with MDMA.
Is that it's such an empathogen
that one could start to-- you
could go down any number
of different rabbit holes.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
But it's also-- it's a
strength, because you well,
the classics like psilocybin
can take you there very reliably
but maybe a bit aggressively.
MDMA makes it
easier to go there.
And that's its strength.
And that's why that marriage
of MDMA therapy for PTSD,
in particular, is a good combo.
It works, because you
are going to go there.
In a sense, you have to really
make the therapeutic progress.
You're going to have
to go back there.
But we're going to set it up
so that you can go back there
and feel safer and
more trusting and be
able to go back there whereas
you've never, otherwise,
been able to go back there
without dissociating or having
horrible flashbacks and so on.
So that's the strength
that it offers.
I guess the limitation
would be that, maybe, it
doesn't take you as deep as
the classic psychedelics.
And I tend to think
I'm biased on this one,
that there's a kind of
honesty to the classics
in that it is hell
as well as heaven.
And that's the psyche.
It isn't all roses.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
really appreciate
that you bring that up.
Because I think that
there's such a fear
of so-called bad trips.
There's such a fear in
non-psychedelic states
to avoid the painful and
everything we know from trauma
and the treatment of trauma.
And we've had several
guests on here.
And my close colleague, close,
close colleague at Stanford,
Dr. David Spiegel, our
Associate Chair of Psychiatries,
Clinical Hypnotist.
Amazing human being and
scientist and clinician,
has really just embedded
this in my mind.
That the only way
to deal with trauma
is to get right up next to
that trauma to the point
where some relief
is experienced.
There is no other real way.
And so, I really
appreciate that you're
saying that the classic
psychedelics may offer
with a very strong
nudge, perhaps,
the opportunity to get into
the uncomfortable in a way
that MDMA or some non-classical
psychedelics, perhaps, do not.
We were talking about time
frames or duration of trips
and these different
compounds and how they differ
and how they're similar.
I'd love for you to educate
me on DMT and some of the work
that you're doing with DMT.
My understanding is that it's
a very brief trip minutes.
People I know who
have done this.
Again, therapeutically,
actually, I'll
just point to one very
exciting, I think,
group and initiative which
is the Veterans Solutions
Initiative, which is a group--
this is carried out in
Mexico, but in conjunction
with laboratories at Stanford
and elsewhere who are
evaluating the neural changes.
And this involves
ibogaine, which
is iboga, which is a very
long duration psychedelic.
22 hours or more, followed by I
think one or two doses of DMT.
This is for veterans to deal
with any number of issues.
Appears to be working
with great success.
And I've spoken
to several people
who've gone through this.
And the way that they described
DMT, almost across the board,
was quote, here I'm just
pulling quotes, right?
Anecdata.
The most profound experience
of my entire life,
even greater than the
birth of my children,
quote, "like being attached to
the shockwave of an atom bomb."
Quote.
"There's no way I
would do another dose,
because the first one
was so unbelievable."
Interesting, by the way.
I think most of
us, including me,
would think, why wouldn't
you want to do it again then?
But this idea that that
was just beyond anything.
So these are
significant-- excuse
me these are significant
statements coming
from individuals
who have existed
at the extremes of human
experience to begin with.
These are so-called
tier 1 operators
within special operations
who exit and may or may not
have trauma.
But DMT sounds like a big deal.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Short
duration, really big deal.
What do we know
about its chemistry?
What do we know about how
it's impacting brain networks?
And what in the
world is going on
that people are
describing it as the ways
I just mentioned
a few moments ago?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
It's a rocket ship.
If the psilocybin is like a
ship leaving port, then yeah.
This is a rocket
ship into craziness.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Is it serotonin 2A?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It is.
Yeah.
So it is a classic psychedelic.
It's a direct agonist, a direct
stimulator of the serotonin 2A
receptor.
It's an order of magnitude
less potent than psilocybin.
But potency is a funny thing,
because it's dose-dependent.
So that doesn't mean that
the experience with DMT
is less than that of psilocybin.
It's just that you
give more of the drug.
But that's matched
by it's stickiness
for the serotonin
2A receptor, which
is this kind of golden rule
in psychedelic sciences
that it was discovered
in the mid 1980s.
This tight relationship between
the affinity or the stickiness
or the binding potential of a
psychedelic for 2A receptor,
in particular.
Serotonin 2A and its potency.
And the stickier the
drug, the more potent.
So LSD really sticky.
Very, very potent.
You only need those
tiny microgram doses.
So DMT, by its affinity,
is a little less potent,
but by its effects when
you give a standard dose,
it's just wild.
And DMT, because there's another
compound called 5-methoxy DMT,
which is a bit different
pharmacologically
and subjectively, it's similar
in terms of its kinetics.
It's another rocket ship.
Both compounds in the wild,
so to speak, are smoked often.
DMT and 5-MeO.
People are vaping
both actually now.
There are vape pens that are
being developed for people
to administer this,
but more traditionally,
it's been a smoking thing.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: This is
clinically not recreationally
or both.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Both no.
I mean, underground
practitioners
are using the vape pens.
They like them because
people titrate the dosage.
They get a feel for what it
is to be going into this state
so that they feel they
can let go and go into it.
And actually, I think
some of the veterans work
might be giving 5-MeO
after the ibogaine.
Phenomenologically, if there's
a difference between DMT
and 5-MeO, people
might put it on 5-MeO
being more of a reliable
ego dissolution experience.
Less visual and more
all round immersion
in the greater whole
loss of self-identity
and just immersion
in everything.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
Maybe we could just talk about
ego dissolution for a second,
because it's such a
sticky, interesting idea.
I can take a step back as a
neuroscientist and say, OK.
Ego dissolution.
This idea that-- from
a very early age,
we have a concept of self and
that I wake up every morning
and I know I'm me and
not somebody else.
And presumably, you do the same.
And most people do the
same, I would hope.
And that there are
objects in the world
and people in the
world beyond us.
But every time I hear
about ego dissolution,
it sounds like it's kind
of a temporary elimination
of the idea that
things start and stop
between us and everything else.
Almost like in a kind
of a-- here I'm not
trying to sound philosophical
or metaphysical,
but there's the molecular
continuity of life, right?
We're all just little bits--
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Which is true.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
--which is true, right?
Not a functional way to
go through the day, right?
Because you want to
make a cup of coffee,
you don't really want
to get lost in that
if your goal is to
make a cup of coffee.
But what is the power
of ego dissolution?
Is it the idea that we belong,
is it a sense of meaning?
Is it the sense that we're
not as important as we think,
which, of course, could be
a wonderfully useful way
to go through life?
To think that we're not as--
like we are vitally important,
but we're not the only thing,
right?
Because I do believe connection
is vital as most people do.
What is ego dissolution?
And why would this serotonin
2A activation cause that?
That's remarkable.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Great questions.
I mean, what is it?
You alluded to it with
the start/stop, I think.
Because you could
define it by boundaries.
In a sense what isn't
me is as valid here
as the a developing
sense of what
is me that a child
develops at whatever age.
And so a major characteristic
of the ego dissolution
experience rather than just a
negative, a thing going away.
My sense of self going
away is the positive.
Oh.
Now, I feel interconnected
with other people and the world
at large.
And I realize that there is
that molecular continuity.
And actually, that's
a ground truth.
And oh, maybe the ego thing is
somewhat illusory or at least
a construction of my mind.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
indeed it is, right?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Well, it is.
Yeah.
I mean, there's no
transcendentalism about that.
It's just not like logic.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I think we
are about it a little bit
like family.
I mean, we all know what
immediate family is, but it's
like--
forgive me for
interrupting myself.
I do it all the time, anyway.
When I teach neuroanatomy,
some clever student
always figures out, OK.
Well, that's connected to
that and that's connected.
But ultimately,
everything in the brain
is connected to everything else.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: There's
just no way around that.
That's a true statement.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
so you really just
have to decide where you
draw the boundaries between--
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Where do you draw the line?
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Where are the modules?
What are the modules?
You could say, the brain is
just one big macro module.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And then you
also want to include the body.
And now fortunately,
people are starting
to embrace this idea that
it's not mind-body, it's both.
Because the nervous
system extends through
both, of course.
So the same could
be said of family.
We're related, right?
Not just by virtue of the
fact that we're human beings.
If we did our
genealogical charts,
we would find a
convergence at some point.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And of course,
this becomes a bit of a game.
But then one realizes that
where you draw the boundaries
and if you draw them at
brother, sister, parents,
biological parents, et
cetera, that's a game too.
And so it is just a construct.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
I mean, it is a fun game.
Where do you draw the
line and when to pass
and when to collapse.
It's also a classic
consideration in science
when to pass and when--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That
lumper versus the splitter.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
There you go.
It's brilliant.
Yeah.
But you asked this
question, like, well,
why does psychedelics do it?
And there, we think
psychedelics do it,
because the target
receptors, at least,
classic psychedelics do it.
And that's important to stress.
So MDMA doesn't really
do it in the same way,
might soften the ego a bit.
But yeah.
That's debatable.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: My
experience with MDMA
is that it's such a
strong empathogen.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And that it
can cause empathy for others.
Certainly, you could
imagine situations
where one in MDMA
journey and afterwards
says, oh, my oppressors are
the people that harmed me.
And here I'm not referring
to my experience.
But they did the best
with what they have.
Actually have empathy for them.
Forgiveness.
But also for oneself.
That there's an
empathy for self,
I know I said this earlier, that
is very hard for most people
to access.
Perhaps, not the narcissists
out there listening.
They'll be like, of
course, empathy for self.
But everyone else, I think,
all the other healthy people
or the healthy people
other than narcissists
and not picking on narcissists.
I have to imagine
they suffer too.
In fact, I think that's the
root of their narcissism.
That empathy for
self is not something
that comes reflexively
for most people.
And here I'm not talking about
self love or self respect.
But this notion of being able
to see the self as not just
deserving of love and
care but actually holding
that in place while
in confrontation
with something challenging
in a way that allows a more,
not less access to adaptive
responses to that challenge.
I think that's the way
I conceptualize it.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, drugs offer a great--
they offer great-- they
are great scientific tools
for tackling this question.
What is ego dissolution, and
why do drugs modulate it?
And what does that tell
you about the brain?
Because other drugs
like cocaine releasing
more of a different
neurotransmitter,
dopamine more than serotonin.
The opposite is
the case with MDMA.
Is more of an ego
inflator, right?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh, absolutely.
People will become
hyper-linear, hyper-linked
to their own desires and wishes,
and future outcomes become
an obsession.
It's the stuff of
American Psycho
and the cliches and stereotypes
of the '80s cocaine culture.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
We did a study once
actually looking
at dose-dependent relationship
with ego inflation
on one axis and ego
dissolution on the other
and saw that it just massively
passed or differentiated
between cocaine
and psychedelics.
It's quite a neat study.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So cocaine makes
people's egos super inflated?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And doesn't touch
dissolution and the opposite
is the case with psychedelics.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Is
there any neuroimaging
to explain how
cocaine does that?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: That
would be a great study.
Yeah.
Great idea.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
We should do that.
I have a sabbatical coming up.
I've got 12 months of
sabbatical coming up.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
That's--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm going
to show up in your lab.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
That's a really good one.
If it's all right to finish
the thread on why psychedelics
and ego dissolution,
we do know some things
or we have some hypotheses.
And it's that the target
receptors, the serotonin 2A
receptors that classic
psychedelics hit,
are heavily expressed
in what these days I
like to call recent brain.
Because evolutionarily,
it's recent brain.
It's cortex that humans have
more than any other species.
If you look at a mapping of
cortical expansion from say,
macaque or chimp to human,
it's the very same map
that you'll find
the 2A receptors in.
So that's the target.
And it's just easy to
think that-- oh, well, that
could be the egoic brain and the
classic psychedelics come in.
They scramble up the activity.
That's the entropic
brain action.
And in terms of the
start/stop, the boundaries,
that entropic action
spreads out the system.
It doesn't shut it off.
It spreads it out.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Dissolution?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And you were talking about
the headspace as well.
So that fits.
If it's more capacious, it fits.
The big qualifier with
psychedelic therapy
that people rightly bring
up is it doesn't last.
That's the paradox of it.
The paradox of ego dissolution.
So the ego might go
away during the trip,
and you have these
profound insights
about the molecular continuity
and how we're all one
and interconnected.
And then you come
down, and however
long later, the ego comes back,
but maybe with a vengeance.
And sadly, things
can go awry when
people haven't done the work.
Perhaps haven't
done the integration
work and maybe ego
defenses come back
and it's not a pretty picture.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: How often
do you see that in the trials
that you do?
What percentage of
people coming through
do you think end up
with worse than they
were before the trial?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: It's
very rare in the trials
that we've done.
Yeah.
But you see defenses come back.
So you do see people relapse.
That's more-- if
you're pushing out
to like three months plus
in something like treatment
resistant depression,
that's more the rule
than the exception sadly.
People relapse.
If their histories are
histories of chronic depression,
then while you might give
them a window of wellness,
sadly, it doesn't last.
That's not to say that
it doesn't ever last.
It does.
And we have people who
are in our first treatment
resistant depression
trial who are
well to my knowledge
today, back at work
doing fantastically well.
But sadly, the majority have
relapsed, to my knowledge.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And need to
do more psychedelic journeys.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Well, they
can't, because it's illegal.
That's been the really
difficult situation
that we've been up against.
Is that we do a trial where
all of a sudden this schedule 1
drug becomes a
medicine in the trial,
or at least an
experimental medicine.
We give the treatment, it
works fantastically well,
gives people a remission
that they've never really
had for however long,
and then the trial ends
and they're denied
that treatment.
And worse still, if they
were to have that treatment,
they would be
committing a crime.
It's a sick joke in a way.
But that's the situation
that we've been in.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
that's a perfect segue
for what I want to
talk about now, which
is, what is the current
state of legality
in terms of-- or the
progression towards legality.
I'd also like to touch on
the role of, let's just say,
incoming big pharma.
There are a lot of start
up companies now trying
to capitalize on
these discoveries
that you and others have made.
The landscape out there
is very unclear to me.
Maybe I'll just call out
some silos as I see them
and maybe we can draw
some bridges between them,
if they exist.
At the ground level,
not the grassroots,
but at the ground level,
I look to laboratories
like yours, Matthew
Johnson's, Roland Griffith's
some laboratories at Stanford.
Nolan Williams.
Laboratories studying the
effects of psychedelics
in human beings, so
not animal models,
in terms of their clinical
application for the treatment
of depression, anorexia.
I now know fibromyalgia, trauma.
Let's lump MDMA
in there as well,
assuming that it all
works in equivalent way
at the level of where the
legislature is taking things.
OK.
So labs using government
money, philanthropy, et cetera.
Then there are the
therapists out there
that are accessing
what we believe
are clean sources of MDMA.
Psilocybin, LSD to do this.
They are doing it illegally.
This is in the US or other
Western European countries,
because, obviously, it's
going to differ by country.
Who are administering
these things
on the basis of what they're
reading in these studies
that you all are publishing.
But also expanding on
and experimenting hippie
flips and combination drugs
and ketamine and et cetera.
But let's leave ketamine out
right now because it's legal.
But there's that.
Then there's the--
I don't want to say
recreational/open market,
black market.
And here I want to
raise a flag to the fact
that Dr. Peter Attia did
a terrific podcast on this
recently in his own
podcast, The Drive.
The fact that fentanyl--
lacing with fentanyl
is now showing up in MDMA
and psychedelics that
are purchased on the street.
So serious caution
to those getting it
from uncertain sources.
And then you've got pharma.
And then as an umbrella
for all of this,
you've got the FDA and law
enforcement agencies, which
currently say, this
stuff is illegal
unless it's being used
in a clinical trial.
Selling it or possessing
it can get you charged
with a crime ranging from--
I don't want to say
because I don't know.
But up to felonies.
Right years in prison.
So can't take it
through airports,
don't get caught with it,
don't buy it, don't sell it
kind of thing.
So where are we going from
that picture of the silos?
I know things are in
clinical trials now.
Most people, including
myself, are not
familiar with how the different
phases relate to the proximity
to legality.
Could you just give us the
landscape and touch on how long
you think it will
be before the people
that come through
your trials could then
go get a prescription
for psilocybin
or potentially buy
it without the risk
from a reliable
source, one would hope,
but without the risk of
getting thrown in jail.
I used to live in
Oakland, California.
My understanding-- and please
correct me if I'm wrong, folks.
Don't trust this information
and get in trouble.
My understanding
is that psilocybin
is decriminalized in
Oakland, but that's
not the same as being legal.
So what is going on out there?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
Wow.
Well, so much.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
I just asked 55 questions.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: I know.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: But feel free
to answer just a subset of them
if you like.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
Well, Oakland's a funny one.
I live close to Oakland.
There are head shops
in Oakland that
might be selling cannabis and
cannabis-related paraphernalia
that are selling
mushrooms as well.
Psilocybin, mushrooms--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's a fact.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: --openly.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's a fact.
I can verify that.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: OK.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
haven't purchased them,
but I've gone in and checked
it out, what's going on here.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
So the police aren't
going to prioritize
that activity, the purchasing
of those mushrooms as a crime
now in Oakland because
of the decriminalization.
So those head shops shouldn't
strictly be selling.
Well, they shouldn't be selling.
They won't have a
license to be selling.
Licenses don't exist
yet for that here.
But let's see whether
they get shut down.
They probably
will, I don't know.
But there's a church
in Oakland sort of
say that they're selling and
it's part of religious rights.
They're using that church
model as a loophole, the way
that Native Americans
can use peyote
and they have a more
genuine case, I think.
Because there is
a history there.
But they're trying to
kind of piggyback on that.
Anyway, that's close to
where we are right now.
But federally, which is really
the major inflection point,
is the FDA and the licensing
of psychedelics as medicines
to be legally prescribed across
the country, across the US
and beyond, that is close
because the key phase--
so there are different
phases of clinical trials,
and the key one to know
about is phase III.
Phase III trials are
licensing trials.
If they're successful,
and typically you
have to do at least
two successful ones,
show the results to
the regulators who
are the FDA, the medicine
regulators, and say,
is this good enough now for
you to give me a license
so that I can sell and provide
this medicine that we've
demonstrated is a medicine.
So that work has been
done with MDMA therapy
for post-traumatic
stress disorder.
MAPS have led that work and
done two phase III trials.
I think they've already
publicly announced
that the second
trial had results
consistent with the first.
We know the results
of the first,
because they're published and
they were remarkably good.
Something like 67%
remission rates.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And long term.
My understanding is
some of those remission
rates for trauma were years,
which is different than what
you're describing
for psilocybin,
where people might
need ongoing dosing.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
That's true.
Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
But of course, just
for trauma in those trials.
My understanding is those
MDMA trials were not
focused on depression.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yes.
Yes.
Focused on the trauma.
So that's something,
because that data
is being filed now, to my
knowledge, like as we speak.
And they're anticipating
a decision maybe this year
with rollout happening
as early as next year.
I mean, that's
best case, I think.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Could I ask you
when you, when you say rollout,
and it's the appropriate
term for MDMA, because
of so-called rolling.
About 20% of my
audience, maybe 50
will understand that not
funny joke that I made.
Who's going to roll it out?
Where would one get the
clean source of MDMA,
meaning not laced with fentanyl,
not laced with methamphetamine,
not undergone any
chemical conversion
to some other drug which can
happen with extended shelf
life, et cetera.
Are people going to go to
their psychiatrist to get MDMA?
And who's going to
be providing it?
Is it going to be
some big major pharma?
This seems like a
serious set of issues.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Mhm.
It is.
And I don't have
all the answers.
I do know that MAPS would be
providing, because they've
done the work and they have
set themselves up in a sense
to potentially
become the provider,
whether as a pharma company,
which is the big question
they're wrestling
with at the moment.
It's very expensive to
become a pharma company.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And yet
they probably deserve
to make the choice,
because they've
put in so many years of hard
work when all of this stuff
was considered like
raver culture party drug,
they were the ones that spotted
the therapeutic potential.
I mean, we knew there was
therapeutic potential based
on work going back many
decades, but points to them,
and I think in my opinion,
they should have the agency
to make those decisions.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
And it's such a remarkable
thing that's been achieved.
And I think they've done it
all on philanthropic donations.
I think so.
Yeah.
So there is this
big question mark.
And the FDA are also
asking questions about,
to your question,
who can provide this,
because in the phase III
work and up until this point,
there's been a MAPS training,
a MAPS therapist training.
And you have to do this
formal training in order
to be a practitioner
within the trials.
But now, there's a
question from the FDA
whether that MAPS training
can be the training
that a clinician has to
have to now be a provider.
And when I say rollout,
it's like offering this
as a service, essentially.
And so where would the
referral come from?
That's a good question.
That I'm not 100% on the answer.
Whether it would have to come
from a psychiatrist or whether
someone's--
sort of general physician
could do that referral.
But they will be going
to a provider who
is licensed and certified and
will have done some training.
And there will be
a consensus on what
constitutes good enough
training to provide.
There will also be
some stipulations
on the basic underlying
professionalism
of the clinician who provides.
So I imagine, they'll have to
be a mental health professional.
I don't think they would have to
necessarily be a psychiatrist,
they could be, I think,
a clinical psychologist.
For all the dosings, I
think without question,
there would have to be a
physician present or at least
within ready access in
case of an emergency.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, especially,
with MDMA because of the
propensity for cardiac issues.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Because of
the amphetamine properties.
And where is psilocybin in
terms of the phase trials?
Is it in phase II, phase III?
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
It's in phase III.
There's psilocybin
therapy work being
done for treatment
resistant depression
by a company called Compass.
Those trials which
are always multi-site.
So there's always a bunch
of teams or labs in a sense.
Geographically spread
out that are each
contributing to data that
then gets matched together
and is then submitted as part
of the phase III trial results.
So that's happening
with Compass right now.
It's psilocybin therapy for
treatment-resistant depression.
Those trials have
just started and I
think the earliest
estimate that I
heard in a journalistic
article was
because I don't think
Compass would say
or they wouldn't say
publicly something like 2026.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: '26.
Wow.
So MDMA is ahead of psilocybin.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's quite a few years ahead.
And it's more of,
not a certainty
but it's very, very
strong position with MDMA.
Whereas the work's
only just begun
with psilocybin in terms
of the phase III trials.
But then you have
this other situation
of however many psychedelic
research centers
there are now across the globe,
we had the first one in London
in 2019.
The first one in
2019, it's 2023 now,
and I don't know
how many there are.
But so much has happened in
such a small space of time.
Yes.
But all these
different indications
I've been able to tell
you about-- anorexia
and fibromyalgia syndrome.
Trying to do a trial
with a colleague of mine
at UCSF in methamphetamine
use disorder.
He's got a trial going
on in Parkinson's disease
and chronic lower back
pain and bipolar disorder.
I mean, there's
so much going on.
OCD.
Almost the full gamut of
psychiatric disorders.
Not schizophrenia, to my
knowledge, are being looked at.
So there's so much
groundswell of activity.
And I think these small
investigator-led studies,
typically, they're small
because trials are expensive,
are going to be reporting
positive results.
I know what we're seeing.
And it will be four--
let's see now, at
least four trials all
with really positive results
in very difficult-to-treat
disorders.
And that's just us.
And I know there's
so much elsewhere.
Addiction disorders as well.
Mike Johnson's work,
obviously, Michael Bogenschutz.
So all this compelling
groundswell,
it's really something.
And yet the system
to really make
a big breakthrough in terms of
licensing is, of course, slow.
And that can frustrate people,
but it has to be done properly.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
Else we revert back to
what happened in the '70s
where there was a lot of
interest in psychedelics.
It's interesting to me.
There was a close
juxtaposition of meditation
and behavioral approaches to
self-directed state change
and psychedelics.
Meditation made it
through the hatch.
I mean, there were
some years where
it was considered counterculture
woo magic carpet weirdo
stuff by Western science.
But now, I mean, there are--
probably tens of
thousands is not
an overstatement of
quality studies exploring
how meditation can provide
advantages for the mind
and even for mental health.
And psychedelics
are now catching up,
but they used to
be close cousins
in the cultural framework.
But the problem was,
I think, psychedelics
were viewed as
making people crazy.
And university professors
lost their jobs
for having discussions
like the one
that you and I are
having right now.
And some people went to
jail, but mostly people
either left academic
institutions
or lost their jobs, whereas
now these are some of--
these studies of the
sort that you are doing
and that are taking place
at Stanford and Hopkins and
elsewhere are some of the
greatest magnetic pull
for philanthropy
for universities.
Donors are very
interested in supporting
these sorts of studies, because
they and their family members
and people they know suffer from
psychiatric illness for which
the current big pharma
approaches simply have not
worked.
So it's interesting
to me that what once
was seen as poison
is now being viewed
as a potential therapeutic.
It's not just
interesting, hopefully,
it speaks to the evolution
of the human species.
People seem to be coming more
open-minded about becoming
more open-minded.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Right.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
And yet-- yeah.
There's so much that's
happening so fast.
And there are elements of--
it's complexifying the space.
There is critique, there's
been some bad practice
in psychedelic therapy,
boundary crossing issues
that have caused some scandals.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: That's too bad.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS: Isn't it?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
Well, I think too the
gene therapy, right?
It just takes one bad incident.
Gene therapy was on a fast
track three decades ago
and then sadly, a child died
in a gene therapy trial.
And it's like shut down
gene therapy practically
for half a decade
and then it slowly
started ratcheting up again.
Gene therapy broadly
defined, and now we're
in the age of potential
directed gene therapy using
CRISPR and things
of that sort, which
makes some people cringe and
other people very excited.
If you have Huntington's
in your family,
CRISPR is like the most
exciting technology ever,
because you could potentially
eliminate it from your family
line going forward, of course.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
So I just really hope
that we can be balanced
as this all plays out.
Because it could go similar
way given the stigma, given
the history that people would be
very twitchy with some isolated
incidents.
And overgeneralize them,
perhaps, in a sense,
shining a light
on them, I think,
is important that
has happened recently
is important, because
it really drills home
how important it is that
this work be done right
and what the necessary
safeguards and standards should
be.
Yeah.
And it won't be an
easy road forwards.
But let's hope-- we've got
to hope that it succeeds,
because current
treatments-- people talk
about the mental health
crisis and to your point
earlier about
anorexia rates, it's
not always actually
the case when
you look at the epidemiology.
When you look at
the data that you
see a big inflection
in diagnoses or cases
of psychiatric illness.
I would say, it's more--
the treatments haven't moved.
They haven't really progressed.
They haven't got any better
since the 1950s more or less.
And new drugs have
been more of the same.
So there haven't been
any paradigm shifts.
And that's why I get
a little impassioned
when I talk about psychedelic
therapy and that point
that this is
something different.
It's not a drug every day.
That system, it's
not cutting it.
Do we really want to
keep on with that system?
Sure.
Not everyone will want to trip.
And that will
terrify some people
so much that they'll
just want to be
on their Lexapro or a
non-psychedelic, psychedelic,
or whatever.
And of course, it should be
allowed to have those options.
Of course.
And the more
options, the better.
But I think there is great
value in really understanding
what psychedelic therapy is.
And I think when
you do, you realize
that it is a major paradigm
challenge on many levels.
And the fact that it's
different might be its greatest
appeal at the moment, I think.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Well, I am certainly
grateful for your passion for
the potential for psychedelics
to be added to the array
of potential treatments.
And I really also appreciate
how much you put it in there
alongside the other treatments.
Maybe even in combination
with other treatments
as opposed to saying,
this is the thing that's
going to cure everything.
And yet the passion
that you have
for this potential paradigm
shift, the one that really
appears to be happening at
the level of clinical data now
is so important.
So I want to extend
a voice of gratitude
for that and for the
work that you're doing.
I mean, I've been
outside of this field,
but as a neuroscientist, I've
been paying careful attention
to it really for the last
five, seven years or so.
And it's abundantly
clear that it
is a small group of individuals
who are really thinking
in terms of how the
system works now
and what needs to be
done in order to change
the system for the
better like yourself
that are really the driving
force behind this new movement
or paradigm shift.
That without question,
is going to lead
to improvements in mental health
and physical health outcomes.
So I just want to say
thank you for that.
Also thank you so much for
joining us today to share
this immense knowledge set about
the history of psychedelics.
What they are, what they aren't.
Their clinical applications
as seen in your laboratory
and other laboratories.
I'm sure people
already notice this,
but you're incredibly generous
in terms of attribution
and also in your
caution about explaining
how some of the
results in particular,
on anorexia, fibromyalgia, are
perhaps preliminary but very
exciting.
They're not published
yet, anyway.
We wouldn't call
them preliminary.
And also for touching
on mechanism.
That is not just about people
feel better, but pointed
to some potential
underlying mechanisms
in terms of connectivity
changes and on and on.
So thank you so much
for your time today.
Thank you for the work
that you're doing.
And thank you for the work
that is sure to continue.
We will provide links to
studies in your laboratory,
links to your laboratory
so people can learn more
and support in the ways that
they deem appropriate for them.
But just thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Such important work
you're doing, Robin.
ROBIN CARHART-HARRIS:
Thank you, Andrew.
It's been a pleasure.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Thank
you for joining me today
for my discussion with
Dr. Robin Carhart-Harris.
I hope you found it to be as
informative about the science
and clinical uses of
psychedelics as I did.
If you'd like to learn more
about Dr. Carhart-Harris's
research or support that
research or inquire into being
a research subject in one
of his laboratory studies,
please see the links in
the show note captions.
In addition, please
see the links
to his Twitter account and
other social media accounts
also in the show note captions.
Also in the show
note captions you'll
find a link to Dr.
Carhart-Harris's Twitter
account where he regularly
posts about new advances
in the field of
psychedelic science.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on both Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can also leave us up
to a five-star review.
Please also check
out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you have questions
for me or comments
about the podcast or
suggestions about guests
you'd like me to include on
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
Not so much on today's episode,
but on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them
for things like improving
sleep, hormone support,
as well as focus.
The Huberman Lab podcast
is proud to have partnered
with Momentous Supplements.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed
on the Huberman Lab podcast,
you can go to livemomentous,
spelled O-U-S. So it's
livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following me on social media,
I am hubermanlab
on all platforms.
So that's Facebook, LinkedIn,
Twitter, and Instagram.
And on all those
platforms, I post
about science and
science-related tools,
some of which overlaps with
the content of the Huberman Lab
podcast, but much of which
is distinct from the content
on the Huberman Lab podcast.
So again, it's hubermanlab on
all social media platforms.
If you haven't already
subscribed to our Neural
Network newsletter, the
Neural Network newsletter
is a monthly newsletter
in which we distill down
the essential points
of particular podcasts
and we list out toolkits
such as toolkits for sleep,
toolkits for
neuroplasticity, toolkits
for optimizing dopamine,
and on and on, all of which
is available at zero cost.
You simply go to
hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu, scroll
down to newsletter,
and supply your email.
And we do not share
your email with anybody.
Thank you once again for joining
me for today's discussion
with Dr. Robin Carhart-Harris.
And last but
certainly not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]